I WE'RE GONNA START --
I'M SORRY GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME TO THE AUGUST FIFTEENTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING.
THE ONE BILLS TO CONSIDER TODAY --
SOME OF THESE I KNOW WE HAVE
SOME --
TESTIMONY.
AND I AM.
MY HOPE IS TO GET THROUGH THESE
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THE
TESTIMONY THAT WILL BE TAKEN WE
WILL ALLOW. TO FOLKS ON A PORT
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFIED FOR A
STRICT TWO MINUTES EACH IF YOU
GO OVER YOUR TIME TO GET FOUR
MINUTES AND I'M AND CUT YOU OFF.
AFTER THAT IT'S JUST --
BLOOD WHO YOU ARE WHO YOU
REPRESENT YOUR POSITION --
WITH THAT I CAN GET THE TIMER TO
WORK.
NOW HOW THIS WORKS.
WE ARE GONNA GO AHEAD AND START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE NOTING ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM WILL START WITH DR
ED.
SEE IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A FEW.
SENATOR HERNANDEZ --
IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
S. B. NINE NINE TWO AS A CONSENT
ITEM IS THAT CORRECT THAT IS IN
ALSO S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
IS A CONSENSUS LOW FAT IS.
IN THAT I'M GOING TO BE
PRESENTING A ONE ONE ZERO EIGHT
ONE ONE FIVE TO TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE YES SIR
THANK YOU. THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M YOU MAY PROCEED TO ANSWER
WITH ELEVEN I WAIT YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
JANUARY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ANNOUNCED A DRAMATIC CHANGE IN
POLICY BY ALLOWING THE STATES TO
CONVEY.
THE CONDITION THE MEDICAID
COVERAGE AND WORK.
AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT FOR
CERTAIN BENEFICIARIES THE
UNDERLYING THEORY BEHIND THE
WORK REQUIREMENT IS THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT WORKING
CHOOSE TO BE UNEMPLOYED.
BUT THERE MAJOR FLAWS IN THE
THINKING FIRST OFF MOST MEDICAID
BENEFICIARIES WHO CAN WORK
ALREADY DO SO.
POSING WORK REQUIREMENTS WILL
ALSO OVER THE BURN SOME
PAPERWORK RESULT IN HIGHER
STATING COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS.
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A LEADER IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED THE HIGHEST GAINS OF
COVERAGE IN THIS COUNTRY.
MAKING MEDI CAL CONTINGENT WORK
REQUIREMENTS IS A STEP BACKWARDS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I DON'T
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CHEN FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER AND
ONLINE POVERTY THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL I THINK THE POLICY
REASONS ARE EVIDENT ON WHY WE
NEED THIS BILL AND WHY WE SHOULD
CONTINUE WITH THE MEDI CAL
EXPANSION HERE IN THE STATE.
AYE AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THE FISCAL EFFECTS ARE
NEGLIGIBLE --
AND SHOULD WE EVER BE IN A
POSITION WHERE CMS IS TRYING TO
REQUIRE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE WORK REQUIREMENTS AS
WE'VE SEEN THEM DOUBLE DOWN IN
APPROVAL LOT OF STATE.
WAIVERS AND FIGHT A COURT CASE
PROVE THEIR APPROVAL OF A WAIVER
WE WOULD WANT THOSE ISSUES TO
COME BACK TO THE ANY ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY TELL THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
MARY VALDEZ HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.%
GOOD MORNING TO TELL ME ASSURE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OTHER DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DOES NOT HAVE A FISCAL
ESTIMATE AS THIS BILL RELATES TO
FUTURE WAIVERS.
HOWEVER FINANCE NOTES THAT
LIMITING STATE FLEXIBILITY TO
PURSUE WAIVERS MAY LIMIT FUTURE
FEDERAL FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS THIS ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE GET AT
COMMITTEE THE LARGE ENOUGH TO
TAKE A VOTE HERE --
WHICH LIKE BECAUSE OF RESPECT
FOR US FROM IBM AND CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO NO IT ALSO
ENJOYS A DO YOU PASS AS IT'S THE
NEXT TIME.
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME QUESTIONS ON THIS LET ME
START BY SAYING WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE SO PEOPLE ARE
AWARE OF HOW AND THE BILL AS AND
I UNDERSTAND YOU ON SEVEN
AMENDMENTS.
SO -- THE
AMENDMENT SPECIFIED BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE LIST OF SERVICES
BE PROVIDED IN A CLINICAL CARE
AREA UNLESS MEDICALLY INDICATED.
THEY REMOVE LANGUAGE REQUIRING
THE DESTINATION TO BE IDENTIFIED
AS SAFE AND APPROPRIATE IN
CHANGES TRANSPORTATION STANDARD
TO THIRTY MILES OR THIRTY
MINUTES.
THERE'S ALSO OTHER MINOR CHANGES --
AND IT REQUIRES HOUSE MUST
INCLUDE A WRITTEN HOMELESS
PATIENT DISCHARGE PLANNING
POLICY PROCESS WITHIN ITS
ESTABLISH HOSPITAL DISCHARGE
POLICY WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO BEGIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ON THIS BILL IS SEEKING
TO IMPROVE THE WAY HOMELESS
PATIENTS ARE DISCHARGED FROM
HOSPITALS.
MY STAFF AND SPONSORS HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
HOSPITAL AND PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS TO
ADDRESS.
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE CAN.
AS PART OF THE EFFORT I AM HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKING THE WORK OUT
WITH YOUR STAFF WHICH REDUCES
HOW FAR HOSPITALS.
ARE OBLIGATED TO OFFER
TRANSPORTATION AND CLARIFIES AND
NONCLINICAL THINGS LIKE OFFERING
A MEAL WHICH CAN BE PROVIDED
OUTSIDE OF THE CLINICAL AREA.
SAYS TO REDUCE THE IMPACT OF
EMERGENCY ROOMS WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
MUCH BETTER POSITION WITH A
HOSPITAL PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY.
EVEN IF WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
RESOLVE THEIR OPPOSITION
ENTIRELY WITH THAT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I VOTE.
SPEAKERS IT'S FINE MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KIMBERLY CHEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK PARTY A CO SPONSOR OF S.
B..
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S FACING TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES AND HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSE WILL PLAY
A CRITICAL ROLE IN CARING FOR
THIS.
VERY VULNERABLE POPULATION THIS
BILL WOULD HELP WOMEN OR EVEN
PREVENT COSTS RELATED TO
HOSPITAL READMISSIONS SETTING A
REASONABLE HUMANE STANDARD FOR
HOSPITALS CARE FOR THIS
POPULATION.
STUDIES SHOW THAT YOU HOMELESS
PATIENTS HAVE HIGHER READMISSION
RATES OF THE OTHER PATIENTS AND
OFTENTIMES --
FOLKS LAND RIGHT BACK IN THE
YOUR AFTER BEING DISCHARGED THIS
CAUSES PRESSURES ON EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHO SEE PATIENTS CYCLE THROUGH.
HIS COSTS INCURRED BY TAXPAYERS
WHO PAY FOR THESE LITTLE
SERVICES THEIR COST OF THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET WHEN A
PERSON'S CONDITION DETERIORATES
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T --
PROPERLY CARE FOR AND DISCHARGE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT COSTS --
RELATED TO FREQUENT AND
PREVENTABLE HAAS MISSIONS CAN BE
LIMITED THROUGH DISCHARGE
PLANNING AND SERVICE CORPS
NATION AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
THIS BILL SUCH A CLEAR PROTOCOL
THAT WILL ENABLE HOSPITALS TO
PROPERLY TREAT THESE PATIENTS
AND MAKE ONE HAND OFF SOCIAL
SERVICES HOUSING.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IPHONE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACTUALLY
I'M.
NO SPAM EQUIPMENT LIKE TO
ESTABLISH HAPPY FOR HIM OR
EGGMAN SECRETARY [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
GROW THEIR CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAPTER EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
READ GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK AND REYES HERE.
THANK YOU RENOWNED FULL
COMMITTEE.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MITCHELL
COVERED IT UP WITH THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
AND WE REPRESENT HOSPITAL
WORKERS INCLUDING SOCIAL WORKERS
WHO DO DISCHARGE PLANNING
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO HAVE
POLICIES AND PROCESSES IN PLACE
TO DISCHARGE PATIENTS.
AND WHAT WE NOTICED ABOUT
EXISTING LAW IS THAT IT IS
WRITTEN WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A HOME AND
FAMILY AND FRIENDS TO GO TO ONCE
THEY ARE DISCHARGED.
AND SO WE SAW THAT THERE WAS A
GAP IN EXISTING ONE THAT IT DID
NOT PROVIDE GUIDANCE FOR WHAT TO
DO WHEN THAT PERSON HAS NEITHER
OF THOSE THINGS.
THIS LAW SEEKS TO SPELL SET OUT
DOWN THE REASONABLE STANDARD FOR
WHAT THE FOR WOULD BE WHAT'S THE
MINIMUM REQUIRED --
WE ATTEMPTED TO OF WORKOUT
REASONABLE SOLUTIONS WITH THE
HOSPITAL'S TAKING OVER TWENTY
FIVE AMENDMENTS TO ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS --
AND SO WE THINK THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND SOMETHING THAT IS
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH THAT IT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED WITHIN WHAT MOST
HOSPITALS ARE ALREADY DOING IT I
HAVE TO SAY THAT MANY OF OUR
HOSPITALS GO FAR ABOVE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL.
BUT WE WANTED TO SET A HUMANE --
FOR FOR TO CATCH SOME OF THOSE
OUT LIARS OF THOSE SITUATIONS
WHERE WE WERE SEEING PATIENTS
ROUTINELY DESTRUCTION HOSPITAL
GOWNS OR TWO LOCATIONS THAT WERE
UNKNOWN TO THE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS BILL IS
VERY TIMELY IN THAT IN THIS AREA
WHERE WE HAVE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS AND SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ARCHER I THOUGHT ON THIS MAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARY VALDEZ HEALTH ACTS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GEN FLORI WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF WE MAKE SOME ROOM UP AT THE
AYE I'M ASSUMING THERE'S A
PRESENTATION AND OPPOSITION TO
MY ROOM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BARBARA
GLAZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE
A POSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR HIS STAFF IN THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS THEY
HAVE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS WHICH DEFINITELY HAVE
HELPED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED FOR TWO PRIMARY REASONS
THE FIRST REASON IS BECAUSE OF
THE PREEMPTION LANGUAGE THAT IS
IN THE BILL.
THIS WOULD ALLOW A LOCAL CITY OR
COUNTY TO PUT IN PLACE LAWS THAT
ARE STRICTER THAN WATER IN S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO WE SIMPLY
DISAGREE WITH THIS WEEK WE DON'T
THINK THIS BILL SHOULD BE THERE
FLOOR WE THINK IT SHOULD BE THE
CEILING AT LEAST FOR NOW.
SECONDLY THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL AROUND THE COORDINATION OF
REFERRALS WHICH WILL BE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO COMPLY WITH
IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS BECAUSE
THERE ARE NOT RESOURCES IN EVERY
SINGLE COMMUNITY TO WHICH WE CAN.
SEND TO THESE PEOPLE.
TO ON A WEAK CARE FOR THESE
PEOPLE BUT WHEN WE ARE.
DONE GIVING THEM MEDICAL CARE
SOMETIMES THERE ARE NOT SOCIAL
SERVICES AND BAILABLE IN A GIVEN
COMMUNITY.
SO THAT IS THE DILEMMA WE OFTEN
FIND OURSELVES IN.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE DO
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST OPPOSITION.
CAPTION HOUSE GOT WITH UNITED
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATIONS COMMENTS I WOULD
ADD THAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT THIS WILL HAVE ON THE
ARE AS WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT
STUDIES.
IPR DELAYS AREN'T GETTING
SHORTER THEY'RE GETTING LONGER
AND I THINK AS WE HELP MANAGE
THIS POPULATION WERE CONCERNED
HOW THE EFFECTS OF THIS BILL
WILL MANAGE THOSE YOUR ABILITIES.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THEO PALES
REPRESENTING TEN AND HOSPITALS
WE ALSO REMAIN OPPOSED.
A COUPLE OF REAL QUICK POINTS
ONE AM TO I'M SORRY. TO SWEEP
HER NAME CAMP THANK HIM UP.
THING CAO.
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION SHORT
WHERE AGAIN ABOUT THE HOSPITAL
CORPORATION OPPOSE.
START OFF BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR CAN TALK
TO US BUT WE REMAIN OPPOSED
LESSON IN A POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A COST ESTIMATE --
ON THE BILL WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AT THIS TIME HOWEVER
OF FINANCE HAS TAKEN ON A POST
POSITION TO THE BILL --
AS AMENDED ON AUGUST SIXTH
BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE COST
PRESSURES ON HEALTH CARE PAYERS
INCLUDING MEDICAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
OUR SO WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS.
IS THE COMMITTEE --
FINDING THAT THIS WOULD COST THE
UC HOSPITALS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
STILL ARE IN THE FACT.
YEAH THE REASON I'M THIS DOESN'T
GO TO SUSPENSE THAT THERE ARE
STILL MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT
WILL COST AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AT HIGHER EDUCATIONAL SOCIAL
WORKERS HOWEVER THOSE COSTS WILL
BE FUNDED BY PATIENT CARE
REVENUE NOT DIRECTLY BY STATE
AND SO OKAY WITH A PATIENT THERE
IS A COST OBVIOUSLY TO YOU SEE
IN THE US DEPARTMENT HOSPITALS.
TO RIGHT AND WHEN WE SAY PATIENT
CARE REVENUES OF THAT MEANS.
WHAT PEOPLE PAY IN THE HOSPITAL
FROM INSURANCE FROM COPAYS NOW
FOR MEDI CAL ETCETERA?
OKAY -- SO
MY CONCERN IS THAT THE HOSPITALS
IN.
ALAMEDA COUNTY HAPPENS --
RIGHT AND LEFT WE HAVE TO THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN OVER BY THE
COUNTY.
WHICH CAN BARELY AFFORD TO KEEP
THEM OPEN.
AND WE HAVE ST ROSE HOSPITAL
[inaudible]
ARMS I THINK THE LAST PRIVATE
HOSPITAL IN --
THAT'S NINETY THEY'RE PART OF A
HOSPITAL DISTRICT ARE PART OF
THE COUNTY SYSTEM.
OUR OTHER THAN SUTTER.
HIS CLOSING HOSPITALS ANYWAY --
IT'S LIKE IT'S THE ONLY.
HOSPITAL IT TAKES THE HOMELESS
FRANKLY IN MY AREA --
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY AND IF
THEY HAVE TO BRING ON MORE
SOCIAL WORKERS IT CETERA IT
COULD BRING THEM OVER THE BRINK
TO BANKRUPTCY.
NO I AGREE WITH ALL THE POLICY
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP.
IN IF THERE WERE STATE FUNDS TO
FUND SOCIAL WORKERS HOUSE SCENE
AT CETERA.
I BE HOT BEHIND IT A 100% BUT I
AM VERY WORRIED ABOUT MY LOCAL
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL IN HAYWARD.
GOING OVER THE DEEP END --
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR QUICKEN YES
ST ROSE IS ONE OF OUR KEY SAFETY
NET PROVIDERS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND HAS BEEN FOR A LONG TIME
SHOULDERING A LOT OF THE SAFETY
NET OBLIGATIONS IN THE REGION.
AND IT IS PART OF THE REASON WHY
WE TOOK AS MANY AMENDMENTS AS WE
DID TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ON THE OF THE BILL
OR NOT ONEROUS IN ADDITION --
WE WOULD SAY THAT WITH OUR
SAFETY NET EMPLOYERS THEY
ALREADY DO A LOT OF WHAT'S
REQUIRED IN THIS BILL AND THIS
BILL IS DRAWN FROM THE EXAMPLE
OF THOSE INSTITUTIONS THAT DAY
IN DAY OUT SEE THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND ARE.
ARE ACTUALLY MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
ALREADY WITH THEIR SOCIAL
WORKERS I'M ONE MORE THING ALL
SAY IS THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS WE THOUGHT THAT
THEIR ESTIMATE.
FOR THE UC'S WAS HIGH AND
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S INDICATION
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
REVISING THOSE ESTIMATES
ACCORDINGLY BECAUSE WE WE HAD
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT.
ALRIGHT WELL I'LL OVER FOR THE
BILL TODAY BUT I'M GOING TO BE.
CHECKING UP ON THIS WITH MY
LOCALS THANK YOU.
MISS KOREA.
UP FIRST WOULD I'M SORRY DOES
APARTMENT FINANCE WANTED TO
RESPOND TO THAT ARE RIGHT NOW IF
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO I JUST
WASN'T SURE.
WE DO HAVE UPDATED YOU SEE COSTS --
BUT THEY ARE STILL ON
SIGNIFICANT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISCREANT.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS UM AS WELL AS THE
OPPOSITION FOR YOUR POINTS TODAY
I'M YOU KNOW.
LA COUNTY CITY OF LOS ANGELES
LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION IN
STATE.
I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHAT LA COUNTY
HOSPITAL WHICH RECEIVES THE
LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION IN
OUR COUNTY AND I BELIEVE THE
STATE.
BOB WHAT THEY CURRENTLY DO FOUND
THE CITY OF LA HAS ALSO
IMPLEMENTED SOME WARNINGS AS
WELL.
A CURIOUS AS TO THE IMPACT TO
THAT AND I BELIEVE THE IMPACT TO
THE STATE.
PUBLIC VOTING YES ON IT NOW BUT
I DO WANNA DO SOME FOLLOW UP
INCENTIVE DEPENDENCE ON WHAT'S
CURRENTLY BEING DONE AND WHAT WE
DO DO.
FIGURE OUT SOME OF THE UPSET.
SO WE REPRESENT WORKERS AT LA
SEE USC WHICH WE BELIEVE IS THE
LARGEST PROVIDER IN LA COUNTY
FOR HOMELESS SERVICES AND YOU'RE
CORRECT THE LA CITY ATTORNEY HAS
A LOCAL ORDINANCE --
BECAUSE THERE WAS A PATTERN OF
IMPROPER PATIENT DISCHARGES IN
GENERAL IN THE COUNTY AND THAT
RESTRICTS WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE
DISCHARGED AND AGAIN GOES MUCH
FURTHER --
ABOVE THEIR REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS TO SAY THAT LA
COUNTY LA CITY HOSPITALS.
ALREADY EXCEED THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS BILL SO THEY'RE SORT OF
CONTAINED UNDER AT A STANDARD
ABOVE -- WE
TOOK THE PRE --
AMENDMENT IN THE BILL --
BECAUSE LA CITY ATTORNEY FEAR
ASKED US --
TO HE WANTED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO DEAL WITH --
THIS ONGOING SITUATION IN LA AND
IT DOES SORT OF GET TO SOME OF
THAN THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
FACILITIES LA SEE USC FOR
EXAMPLE ALREADY HAS AN ENTIRE
WAITING ROOM DEDICATED TO
DEALING WITH PATIENT DISCHARGES
IN GENERAL FOR EVERYBODY AND SO.
THEY ARE SUPER WELL EQUIPPED TO
DEAL WITH THIS POPULATION THEY
DO IT EVERY DAY OUR MEMBERS HAVE
FLOODING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
AND THEY SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
BRINGING EVERYBODY UP TO A
SIMILAR STANDARD BECAUSE THE
SAFETY NET AS I SAID IS ALREADY
DOING A LOT OF THIS WORK REALLY
WELL [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
IF IF I COULD ADD NOW.
I'M SORRY.
IF THERE'S THAT AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION YOU MAY HAVE IT.
THAT WAS DIRECTED DOT COM THE
PROPONENTS.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
IF NOT I'D SAY THIS --
JUST ENJOY A DAY PASS I THINK AT
THAT FIGHT GIVEN THE FINANCIALS
IT WAS A KIND OF BIZARRE
SITUATION BECAUSE WE LOOK AT YOU
SEE COSTS AN ARM.
IN THE SITUATION IT'S NOT AI
PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL FUND --
SO IT IS.
FISCALLY A BILL THAT --
WE SUPPORT.
AND WILL PUT OUT BUT I'M I THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN STATED CONCERNS
NOT ONLY FOR MEMBERS ON THIS
COMITTEE BUT A NUMBER OF OTHER
MEMBERS THAT I WOULD SUGGEST I'M
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION AROUND THE PREEMPTION
LANGUAGE.
AND IT WAS GOOD TO SEE IT IS LA
CITY THAT CAUSED THE PREEMPTION
LANGUAGE WHICH IS NOW CAUSING
OTHER PEOPLE ANXIETY --
AND SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY I KNOW THERE'S NO
DESIRE TAKEN AMENDMENT ON THAT I
UNDERSTAND WHY AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING CONTINUE
TO BE AN ISSUE FOR YOU --
I THINK YOU KNOW THAT THIS BILL
AND I THINK PROBABLY OTHER
PEOPLE FEEL THIS WAY IN SAN
DIEGO WE'VE HAD A HUGE PROBLEM
WITH UCSD IN PARTICULAR.
DISCHARGING PEOPLE WHEN I FIRST
READ THE BILL I SAID THANK GOD
BECAUSE I AM TIRED OF SEEING
PEOPLE WALKING DOWN THE STREET
YOU NOW.
HALF EXPOSED IN A HOSPITAL GOWN
AND YOU KNOW IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THEM IT'S NOT THAT FAR COMMUNITY
AND I'M I I THINK THERE ARE SOME
NECESSARY STEPS THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN THAT ARE BEING TAKEN A LOT
OF TIMES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
I JUST ADDED I JUST HOPE
[inaudible]
I'M SHOULD MOVE FOR TODAY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AS WELL.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES IT WOULD MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OUT WITH LA TO DO IS
JUST TALK ABOUT COMING FULL
CIRCLE.
WHEN I WAS ELECTED TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY ON TWELVE YEARS AGO I
SAT IN THIS ROOM AND THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE AND A
VERY SIMILAR BILL CAME UP?
THEN SENATOR GIL STUDIO AND IT
WAS A MUCH MUCH MORE CONTENTIOUS
BILLS MANUFACTURE WAS TALKING
HOUSE WILL SOLICITATION HOW
DIFFICULT THAT WAS IN THE THE
DECISION I HAVE TO MAKE.
IT DEALT WITH PENALTIES IF THE
HOSPITAL'S DIDN'T DEAL WITH THIS.
WELL AS YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR THE HOMELESSNESS
PROBLEM CONTINUES TO GROW
DRAMATICALLY.
AND WE'VE READ THE STORIES OVER
AND OVER HOW PATIENTS ARE LEFT
IN THE STREETS EXACTLY AT YOUR
COMMENT.
AND HOSPITAL GOWNS AND BAD
WEATHER.
THIS IS THE MOST VOLATILE
POPULATION WE HAVE AND I FELT
THAT SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE
IF ANYTHING LEAST THE
CONVERSATION TO DEAL WITH THAT
VULNERABLE POPULATION THAT WE
HAVE.
I MADE A VERY CLEAR TO MY STAFF
THAT WE WERE GOING TO TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE COULD. TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T.
THERE IS ACTUALLY NO PENALTIES
HERE.
AND LET ME JUST RESTATE THIS FOR
THE RECORD THE HOSPITALS ARE NOT
THE PROBLEM THE HOSPITALS HAVE
TO DEAL WITH AN ISSUE THAT'S
VERY VERY TROUBLING AMONGST OUR
SOCIETY.
MANY HOSPITALS DO GREAT THINGS
AND WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY THE
PROPONENTS A LOT OF THE
HOSPITALS ALREADY ADDRESSED THIS.
SO IN CLOSING I WANT YOU TO SAY
THIS IS THE FLOOR YES WE HAVE
SOME PREEMPTION ISSUES BECAUSE
IT DOES ALLOW LIKE THE CITIES OF
LOS ANGELES TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND.
I THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES WE HAVE WHAT
WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING WE'VE
CAN'T WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS HAVE TAKEN PROBABLY OVER
TWENTY AMENDMENTS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND UNFORTUNATE WE'RE
AT THE POINT WHERE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE.
TO AGREE TO DISAGREE AND I
REALLY BELIEVE IN THE POLICY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS
THAT HAVE TO BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT AND WITH THAT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MISS A MOTION BY --
IS CHAO IS SECOND BY MISS EGGMAN
AND WE WILL HAVE TO PUT THAT ON
CALL TWIN MOTION --
FOR MISTER HERNANDEZ TO OUR
DOCTOR FINANCES.
ELEVEN OH EIGHT I'M I'M MOTION
BY MYSTERY AS A SECOND MY DOCTOR
QUIRK AND I'M WE WILL ALSO HAVE
TO WAIT WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
FOR NOW.
ALRIGHT DOCTOR HERNANDEZ --
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN I
THINK WE'RE DOWN TO THINK
VENTURE MEMBER THIS MEASURE PUTS
IN THE STATE LAW THE CORRECT A
MEDICAL NECESSITY STAND FOR
CHILDREN ROLE IN MANY CAO.
YOUR STEPHANIE A MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW AND A SECOND BY
MYSTERIOUS THING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I WILL.
REMEMBER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY POW CO SPONSORS OF
THIS MEASURE.
I'M AND IT WOULD JUST LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THIS WOULD ENSURE
CHILDREN GET ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY SERVICES THEIR COSTS
IN THE ANALYSIS POINT OUT THAT
THAT.
ARE MINOR AND SUPPLE AND COACH I
THINK YOU ADDITIONAL SPEAKER
SINCE PART.
MARY BALLOTS WITH HEALTHAXIS IN
SUPPORT.
ZACHARY CORBEAU CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THINK SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CNN DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
FINANCES OPPOSED TO THE SPELL OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ALREADY OFFERS
COMPREHENSIVE ACCESS TO EARLY
PERIODIC SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT SERVICES FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES UP TO EACH.
TWENTY ONE ADDITIONALLY FINANCE
NOTES CONCERNS THAT FUTURE
FEDERAL FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION
COULD BE JEOPARDIZED SHOULD THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MODIFY ITS
DEFINITION OF MEDICALLY
NECESSARY.
RENDERING STATE STATUTE NON
COMPLIANT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO GET OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU.
NEXT UP IS SB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU
MENTIONED MEMBERS DOES YOUR
NAILS INDICATED BILLS MAKES
CLARIFYING CHANGES CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INSURANCE LAWS AND ORDER
TO ENSURE CAR WE HAVEN'T OF
COVERAGE WE MOTION BY MISCREANT
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
NAY VOTE THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BECAUSE
IT WOULD PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
ARE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS BY
CONTINUING THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AND CALIFORNIA LAW. FOR
OVER TWO DECADES CALIFORNIA LAW
HAS REGULATED ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS OFFERED TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
UPDATES THAT LAW IN LIGHT OF
RECENT FEDERAL REGULATIONS BY
CONTINUING OUR EXISTING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
LIKE THE SENSUAL HEALTH BENEFITS
AND INSURANCE MARKET RULES THAT
HELPS STABILIZE THE MARKET FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
AND FOR THIS REASON WE ASK FOR
SUPPORT.
THINK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE MAY EXPERIENCE A
FISCAL IMPACT OF JUST REQUIRED
TO PARTICIPATE IN A LAWSUIT
CHALLENGING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND I SEE NO COMMENTS
WHICH ELECT CLOSE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO ENTER AND THAT BILL WILL GO
ON CALLS.
AND ARE WE DO. FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MIGHT SEEM MOTION BY MY STRESS
AND A SECOND BY DOCTOR PARK.
ENABLE OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
I'M SORRY.
I MISSED THAT WERE NEUTRAL IN
THE STYLE.
I THOUGHT WE HAD IT --
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO PUT THAT
[inaudible]
BILL WELL AS WELL.
I'M THINKING ENSURE MEMBERS
THINK YOU'D.
JACKSON LEAVE IRATE.
I ONLY SEE SENATOR MITCHELL.
COME ON OUT.
ARE YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GONNA START
WITH S. B..
NINE FIVE ONE IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MYSTERIOUS
IN A SECOND BITE AFTER QUIRK.
I DON'T THINK I WILL.
DO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THERESA
COLORED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE ANY
REVENUE IMPACTS.
THANK YOU BACK IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
LET'S GO ON TO S. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR IN GOOD
MORNING COLLEAGUES --
S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY THREE IS A
BILL TO BRING US CLOSER TO A
FAIR AND JUST FORM OF SENTENCING.
THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT NOR THE
COURTS.
STATUTORY DISCRETION TO IMPOSE
OR WAVE THE FIVE YEARS SINCE
ENHANCEMENT ON SERIOUS FELONY
CONVICTIONS.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY MEMBERS YOU
KNOW BY RESTORING THE COURT'S
DISCRETION WE CAN RETURN TO A
SPACE WHERE JUDGES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TAILOR SENTENCES TO
FIT THE INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND WHILE MOST OF THEM HAPPENS
CAN BE DECLINED IF THE JUDGE
BELIEVES THERE AND JUST THIS
ENHANCEMENT IN CURRENT LAW IS
MANDATORY IN ALL CASES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU AND SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
I I AM AMBER ROSE HOWARD OF
CALIFORNIA UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET COALITION OF
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
ON THIS KINDS OF SENTENCING AYE
WE SEE THAT THERE'S JUST A BIAS
IN THE COURTS --
RACIALLY BIASED PRACTICES WHEN
IT COMES --
TO THE THE ENHANCEMENTS WE SEE
THAT -- EVEN
IN THE REPORT THAT COMES OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS --
IF THE JUDGES ARE ALLOWED THE
DISCRETION MEANT TO LOOK OVER A
CASE -- THAT
WE WOULD SEE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF SAVINGS I IN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS OUT WITH A HUNDRED
PACES STRICKEN ADAM. FOR OVER
THE OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD --
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE 90% OF CASES
ARE RESOLVED IN --
PLEA BARGAINS RATHER THAN --
TAKING THE TRIAL BECAUSE FOLKS
ARE --
FACING THESE MANDATORY
ENHANCEMENTS REYES IF THE JUDGE
HAD DISCRETION I'M PROSECUTION
COULD DO THEIR JOB IN THE COURTS --
THE DEFENSE COULD DO THEIR JOB
IN THE COURTROOM AND THE JUDGE
COULD ACTUALLY DECIDE ON
SENTENCING THE WITH THE COURTS
WOULD.
WHO IS HE BIGELOW THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND I'M JUST HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS?
THINK YOU DESERVE MORNING GOING
BACK IS FOR ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE BOTH CO SPONSORS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
BECAUSE RESPONSES WHICH ARE THE
PROBABLY A COSPONSOR.
JUST GIVE ARE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
SHONDA WESLEY SMART JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
EVEN ALL A WITH CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET IN
SUPPORT.
EVAN BUNCH WITH CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
INSULT SUPPORT.
A NOT HERNANDEZ A BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL [inaudible]
I AM.
THIS IS HIGHLY UNUSUAL FOR ME
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL DOES HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I ACTUALLY
THINK THIS BILL WILL SAVE THE
STATE MONEY.
I'M I THINK THE BASICS OF THIS
BILL ARE PHENOMENAL IT'S
SOMETHING I AGREE WITH THAT WE
HAD.
I HAD ASKED FOR AMENDMENTS AND
SELDOM THAT I WILL RECOMMENDED
YOU PASS ASSEMBLY WANTED MY
AMENDMENTS BUT I'LL CLARIFY THAT
THE REASON I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY.
AND WILL NOT BE SPRINT FOR
WITHOUT CHANGING. TO ALLOW
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS OF
ENHANCEMENTS WHEN IT COMES TO
SEX CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN --
FORCIBLE RAPE [inaudible]
AND CHILD MOLESTATION AND THE
REASON FOR THAT QUITE FRANKLY WE
HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSION.
IS -- AFTER
SCENE AFTER WITNESSING IN FACT
ALL OF OUR DISMAY ABOUT JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN THE PROP TURNER
CASE.
AND HOW MEAN --
SEEN A A LOT OF TIMES WHEN AND
JUDICIAL DISCRETION MEANS THAT
THE JUDGE THEMSELVES ARE BIASED.
AND THE RESULT OF THAT
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REPEAT OFFENSES THAT THERE
ARE SO AND CRITICAL TO OUR
COMMUNITY SAFETY.
AND SO WHAT IT COMES TO
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT WHEN IT
COMES A FORCIBLE RAPE I JUST.
IN NOT AT A POINT WITH OUR
JUDICIARY YET BECAUSE WE WE AND
WE TALK ABOUT THIS HOPEFULLY WE
WILL GET THERE WHERE WE HAVE AN
UNBIASED IN MORE REPRESENTATIVE --
JUDICIARY THAT DOESN'T JUST SEE
DEFENDANTS AS THEMSELVES --
IN AND PERHAPS HAVE AND IN SOME
CASES AND MORE LENIENT SENTENCE
SEEN -- ON
CRIMES THAT ARE* THAT WE
WOULDN'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE THERE'S A CONNECTION
THERE --
BASED ON A NUMBER OF FACTORS I'M
I'M JUST NOT COMFORTABLE DISPLAY
WITHOUT THOSE --
EXEMPTIONS AND SO I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY BUT WE
ARE STILL AND I'M GOING TO GET
THIS OUT ON A DAY PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WAS ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
OUR A WITHOUT WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR
THINKING VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE --
YOUR OPPOSITION TODAY AND OUR
CONVERSATION I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT RELY ON IT TO MOVE
TODAY SINCE IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
SCHOOL IMPACT AND REALLY KIND
THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE IS A
POLICY ISSUE.
AND I'LL HOPEFULLY WE GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE THAT FULLER
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
ON IN MY OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
WITH MADAME SHE THE LAUNDRY LIST
OF THE EXISTING SINCE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT TOUCH THAT WOULD CONTINUE
THE IMPACT THE POPULATION AND
THE CHARGES THAT MADAM CHAIR
TALKED ABOUT.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THE REASON I WAS NOT
OPEN TO TAKING AMENDMENTS IS I
AM ALSO CLEAR THAT IT WAS A A A
LEGISLATURE THAT --
LACK TO THE DIVERSITY WE
EXPERIENCED TODAY THIRTY FIVE
AND FORTY YEARS THAT PASSED
BILLS THAT CREATED THE SITUATION
WHICH WE NOW LIVE WITH OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SINCE ENHANCEMENTS ON
THE BOOKS.
I COMPLETELY SUPPORT AND AGREE
THAT WE HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
JUDICIARY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ON OUR TRIP THAT JUSTICE IS
TRULY BOTTOM.
BUT I AM NOT COMFORTABLE
CONTINUING --
IN A CONTEXT IN WHICH A
LEGISLATURE --
THAT LACK OF DIVERSITY THIRTY
FIVE TO FORTY YEARS AGO WHO TOOK
A FAR LEANING ON POSITION ON
BEING TOUGH ON CRIME.
AND TOUGH ON DRUGS POLICIES THAT
WE KNOW NOW THANKS TO RESEARCH
AND ARE YOU KNOW HINDSIGHT IS
TWENTY TWENTY FAILED MISERABLY
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
PARTICULAR SEGMENTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE LOOK AT CERTAIN SAN
ENHANCEMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD WE
EMPOWER THE JUDICIARY TO DO THE
JOB THAT WE PAY THEM.
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO DO.
AND I LOOK TO PARTNER WITH YOU
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S JUDICIARY
[inaudible]
DOES REFLECT THE NEEDS OF THE
ONES THAT THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE AND THAT
JUSTICE IS INDEED BLIND UNTIL
THEN I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
CONTINUING ON WITH A SET OF
POLICIES THAT WERE NOT DEVELOPED --
IN THE TIME ALT WHERE PEOPLE
WERE APPROACHING THIS BODY OF
THE LAW UNFAIRLY AND SO WITHOUT
AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
ACTUALLY APPRECIATE ONE REMIND
PEOPLE THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
STILL DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THAT
RAPE OF AN UNCONSCIOUS PERSON IS
A VIOLENT FELONY SO YES WE HAVE
A LOT OF ROOM TO GO ON RACIAL
DIVERSITY GENDER DIVERSITY AND
THE WAY WE APPROACH THE LOSS IN
THINKING WE WILL WORK ON THAT.
FOR SURE.
AND THAT NEEDS TO GO ON CALL SIR
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR MCCASKEY [inaudible]
YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU NEED NINE THAT'S HERE
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING I S. B. TO NINETY
EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION RIGHT THE STAFF
REPORT INDICATES THAT THE
JUDICIAL CANCEL ANTICIPATES
MINOR COSTS.
WHITTLE THIS DOWN TO A TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR PROTECTION OF A
MINIMUM BALANCE AND PEOPLE'S
BANK ACCOUNTS AND WITH ME IS
JUST A JESSICA PARKER WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
ORIGIN I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTRESS A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JUST
ABOUT THE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND SPONSOR
SUPPORT.
AND JUST TO ADD TO THE FISCAL
CONSIDERATIONS --
YOU WITH THAT THAT AMOUNT
PROTECTED IS A EXPECTED TO HELP
PEOPLE PAY THE RENT.
JUST BECAUSE YOU OWN MONEY
DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T HAVE RENT
TO PAY A WE BELIEVE THAT WILL
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS FROM
ADDICTION --
AND ALSO SAY THE COURTS A LITTLE
BIT OF MONEY WILL BE SEEKING
RELIEF THROUGH THE COURTS ON AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
YES RONALD COLMAN HERE WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION ALSO HEAR THE SPONSOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT CERTAINLY
WE'VE HEARD THAT THIS BILL
CERTAINLY DOES HAVE MINOR COST
TO THE STATE BUT IT DOES HAVE A
VERY BIG IMPACT THE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD BE PROTECTED BY.
THIS BILL CERTAINLY IF YOU HAVE
ALL OF THE MONEY WIPED OUT OF
YOUR ACCOUNT THERE ARE MANY
OTHER CONSEQUENCES AND MORE DEBT
THEY CAN BUILD UP WITH.
DIFFERENT FEES THAT HIT YOUR
ACCOUNT SO CERTAINLY --
THAT YOU KNOW INDIVIDUALS COULD
BE THRUST INTO POVERTY MORE AND
WITH SO MANY INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE EDGE OF
POVERTY OR IN POVERTY.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY IT DOES MAKE
SENSE TO HAVE THIS PROTECTION IN
PLACE FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD HELP
ACCESS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
I THINK WOMEN.
NEED TO MAKE SOME ROOM AT THE
TABLE.
YEAH CHAIR WOMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SORT OF
GIPSON I'M HERE WITH ENCORE
CAPITAL GROUP IN OPPOSITION TO
THE RECENTLY AMENDED THE SENATE
BILL.
TO NINETY EIGHT I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS DO NOT REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THEY ARE VERY
INSIGNIFICANT IT ONLY PRODUCES A
BLANKET NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
DEBT FORGIVENESS ESSENTIALLY OF
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
PREVIOUSLY WAS TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
BANK LOBBIES ARE A A PROCESS
THAT IS A LAST RESORT FOR
CREDITORS IN ORDER TO RECOVER ON
DEBTS THAT ARE OUTSTANDING AFTER
YEARS OF ATTEMPTING TO WORK WITH
CONSUMERS.
THERE'S MULTI MULTIPLE TIMES TO
RESOLVE THE OBLIGATIONS WITH
CONSUMERS.
YOU ARE TAKING AWAY THE TOOL
THAT CREDITORS HAVE. TO GET
REPAID ON OUT SAYING DOT AND
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS SHOULDN'T HELP --
WE SHOULD HELP POOR INCOME
CONSUMERS THOSE PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY PROTECTED THERE'S A TWO
PAGE LIST OF LITERALLY HUNDREDS
OF EXEMPTIONS FROM BANK LEVEES.
THOSE WHO NEED THE PROTECTION
ALREADY GET A BY FILLING OUT A
ONE PAGE CLAIMS EXEMPTION FORM.
BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T KNOW
QUESTIONS BLANKET EXEMPTIONS FOR
EVERYONE WHETHER YOU'RE LOW
INCOME OR HIGH INCOME YOU ARE
TAKING AWAY THE ABILITY DECIPHER
BETWEEN THOSE WHO NEED THE HELP.
AND THOSE WHO DON'T AND THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY CANNOT SUPPORT WHEAT
WE BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
PROCESS PROTECTS LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS IF THERE'S PROBLEMS
WITH THE PROCESS ITSELF.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS AT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS NO
QUESTIONS ASKED EXEMPTION HERE
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT.
WHEN YOU ESSENTIALLY SAY THE TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS CAN BE
PROTECTED IN SOMEONE'S BANK
ACCOUNT THAT IS BANQUET IS
AROUND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS? TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S AND GOODS
AND THE SUBSIDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
BORROWED IT HAS BEEN TAKEN OUT
AS ALONE AS LATE AS OF THE FROM
THE DENTIST OFFICE FROM YOUR
RETAILER.
ANYONE AND EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA NOW CAN SHE'LL TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE BANK
ACCOUNT IF THEY'RE MULTIPLE BANK
ACCOUNTS THEY CAN SPREAD MONEY
BETWEEN AND REPETITIVELY USE IT.
AND I KNOW THE BILL SAYS IT'S
LIMITED.
TO THAT SIMPLY IS UNENFORCEABLE
AND ASKING JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
IMPLEMENT FORMS --
TO HAVE EX PARTE APPLICATION
WITH THE COURTS THESE ARE ALL
VERY COSTLY PROCESSES FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOT TO
MENTION THE FACT THAT NOW YOU'RE
HAVING A LOSS. FOR BUSINESSES
FOR RETAILERS AND IT'S A TAX
REVENUE LOSS FOR THE STATE SO I
DISAGREE JUST BECAUSE WE SIMPLY
CAN'T SIZE THOUGH BROAD IMPACT
THIS HAS I DISAGREE THAT THIS
DID NOT HAVE WITH THIS.
DOES NOT HAVE A FISCAL IMPACT
AND WITHOUT I PLEASE ASK FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
SOURCE I CAN SPEAKER HAS A
MINUTE LEFT OKAY.
I CRISTINA SPEND ONLY FROM CAL
BANKERS AYE WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
HAS AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE TO
VULNERABLE CONSUMERS.
WHICH WAS RECOGNIZED BY MULTIPLE
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR LAST YEAR
AND I REMEMBER IS STAFF WORKING
ON THIS I'M WE BELIEVE THEY CAN
DECREASE ACCESS TO CREDIT FOR
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS BISEXUAL
ESSENTIALLY.
IT CLAIMED ECLIPSING THINK
LEVEES I'M LEAVING CREDITORS
WITH FEW OPTIONS FOR REQUIRES
THAT'S THIS INCENTIVIZING
SMALLER SMALL DOLLAR LOW
INTEREST LOANS.
I'M THE COP AND THE CONCERN IS
SUPPORTED BY MULTIPLE RESEARCH
STUDIES WHICH ALL SPARE YOU THE
DETAILS ON BUT WE HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE FOR YOU --
REDUCTIONS IN AVAILABLE CREDIT
OUT IN AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE
MAINSTREAM CREDIT LEAD TO
CONSUMERS LOOKING TO PAY DAY
LOANS.
INSTALLMENT LOANS AND OTHER HIGH
PRICED FORMS OF CREDIT TO PAY
THEIR BILLS AND I THINK WILD
WELL INTENDED --
BY THE PROPONENTS AS WE TO
NINETY EIGHT ULTIMATELY HARMS
CONSUMERS WHO DEPEND ON CREDIT
TO SURVIVE AND PUSHES THEM
FURTHER OVER THE EDGE.
I AT LONG TERM CREDIT ALSO
IMPACT THOSE CONSUMERS ABILITY
TO BUILD CREDIT AND HAVE A
CREDIT SCORE.
ASIDE FROM TO NINETY EIGHT
BYPASS ROAD SYSTEM PROTECTIONS
IN CREATING AYE ATTENDEES
ASSUMPTION.
I EVEN FOR THE WEALTHIEST
CALIFORNIA ENDS IT ULTIMATELY
HINDERS OUR ABILITY TO LAND
FREELY ASK FOR YOU KNOW VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU JUST OPPOSITION.
TIM WENT ON TO HAVE THE
RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL.
CLIFF BURTON ME HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
MARGARET GLASS HIM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
I'M IN FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
C. NO QUESTIONS I JUST WANNA
KNOW THIS WAS PULLED BACK INTO
MY COMMITTEE SOME.
CHANGE LAST YEAR THAT WAS BEHIND
THE BILL BUT I IT HAS NO.
CHIU FISK LA.
REASON TO BE HERE SO CHOICE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS RACES SECOND BY
MISS KOREA WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
AS AN ANALYSIS NOTES THE OUR
COSTS ARE MINIMAL AND THE
BENEFITS ARE IMMEASURABLE HIGHER
TONIGHT.
AND I'M LIKE IT'S OUT ON OF THE
ROLL CALL NOW THAT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF FOLKS HERE I WILL SAY
S. B. ELEVEN OH EIGHT MISTER
HERNANDEZ GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY TWO MISTER
HERNANDEZ THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE MISTER HERNANDEZ THAT GETS
OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
MISTER HERNANDEZ THAT GETS OUT
ON B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
OBERNOLTE VOTING I SP THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE MITCHELL THAT GETS
OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL.
WITH THE CHAIR NOT VOTING.
YOU MAY PROCEED NOW THIS IS MORE
MOVE TO A. B. R. SP AT THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE THIS CREATES A
CONSISTENCY REQUIREMENT TO APPLY
ALL THE STATE'S LOCAL PLANNING
AND ZONING.
ORDINANCE REQUIREMENTS TO
CHARTER CITIES IN RECENT A
PALETTE --
DECISION PERMITTED HUNTINGTON
BEACH ADOPT THIS IS SPECIFIC
PLAN THAT DIFFERED FROM ITS ITS
HOUSING ELEMENT WITH ME I HAVE
SUCH A HARD MAN.
IN THE WESTERN CENTER AND BRIAN
I GUESS THAT WITH A THE HOUSING
ADVOCATES HAS ANNOUNCES POINTS
OUT THE BILL BE NO I FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE STATE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
INTO SECOND BY MISS REYES YOU
CAN PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING TURNED MEMBERS MY
NAME'S ALEXANDER HER NAME WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND WORK BECAUSE
SPONSORING THIS BILL --
AS MENTIONED THIS BILL WOULD
CORRECT A RECENT DECISION THAT
ALLOWED A CHARTER CITY TO TAKE
DEVELOPMENT IN ZONING DECISIONS
INCONSISTENT WITH IT STATED
PLANS FOR ACCOMMODATING REGIONAL
HOUSING NEED --
LOCAL ZONING IN DEVELOPMENT
DECISIONS MADE BY CITIES HAVE
CONSEQUENCES THAT REACH BEYOND
CITY BOUNDARIES AND WE HAVE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL CITIES ARE
PLAYING BY THE SAME RULES --
AND DOING THEIR PART.
TO FOLLOW THEIR STATED PLANTS SO
THIS BILL --
PRESERVES THE ABILITY TO TAILOR
PLANS TO LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
JUST REQUIRES THAT ONCE THOSE
PLANS ARE ADOPTED THAT THEY'D BE
FOLLOWED.
AND WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT THING.
BRIAN AGAINST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PLEASED
SPONSORED BILL GENEGO.
SPEAKER ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SIMON A
FINANCES NEUTRAL NOBEL.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY.
HA HA I AM IN AN IN BETWEEN
POSITION SYLVIA SOLELY SEAN
BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI --
WE HAD CONCERNS WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE VERSION OF THE BILL
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN PRINT
HOWEVER WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL.
VERY POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS AND
WE HOPE THAT THE NEXT OF
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS ALL OF OUR
CONCERNS I JUST WANTED TO STATE
THAT ON THE RECORD AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
[inaudible]
THINK.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL THINK.
WHICH I CLOSE.
AIR TIME BOTH THAT GETS OUT ON
B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
CASKEY [inaudible]
MISS LEYVA.
MISS LEYVA YOU HAVE S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MYSTERIOUS IN A SECOND BY A
DOCTOR QUIRK WHICH I PROCEED.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK RISK
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR PRIVACY
CAUGHT ME OFF GUARD THANK YOU GO
ON IF YOU'D LIKE ME TO KNOW IT
NOW THAT'S GOOD OKAY COULD
PRESENT A STRIKE WHERE DO WE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MARK WINDOWS WITH ASCII YOU ARE
CALIFORNIA WE ARE THE SPROUT
SPONSORS THAT THIS MEASURE AND
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS ARE
SPEAKERS A SPORT.
YOU'VE GOT A QUICK I I
APPRECIATE THAT I I LIKE IT HOLD
ON THOUGH BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL
SUPPORTERS ARE.
EIGHT WE NEED ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES IN
SUPPORT.
SARAH FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CATHERINE'S GOT IN THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
NIGHT HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION JUST
PROSPER ASSOCIATION I'M
UNFORTUNATELY ARE IN OPPOSITION
WE BELIEVE THIS MEASURE IS
DUPLICATIVE AND WILL COST
HOSPITAL'S.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS DOLLARS AS
THEY TRY TO ADJUST CENTER STAFF
RATIO FOR UNFORESEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING WINNER
STEPS OFF QUICKLY TO MANAGE AN
ILLNESS OF THEIR OWN AND WE
BRING THE FLOATER NURSE AND
BECAUSE OF THE STRICT LIABILITY --
WE BELIEVE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
FLEXIBILITY AND THEREFORE ASK
FOR AN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU PART OF FINANCE.
THIS BILL RESULTS IN COST OF
SIXTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN GROWING
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FROM THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU CHUCK CLOSE.
BIG MEN CHAIR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATE ABOUT.
YOU HAVE AND ONE BELL IS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT ON I
ASSUME S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION --
DIMENSION BY MISS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK
[inaudible]
ORIGINALLY VOCAL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
YES GOOD MORNING NICK BROKE
SEGMENT AB.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION.
HOW PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL?
GRIEF COMMITTEES ANNOUNCES THIS
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS OF APARTMENT THE
HOSPITALS IN COUNTY JAIL
ADMINISTRATORS AND CZECH WE ASK
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THINK DANIEL SO YOU KNOW
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ARE GOING TO PRIOR
COMMENTS VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WELL FINANCE HAS NO CONCERNS
WITH THE POLICIES TO SHORTEN THE
COMPETENCY COMMITMENT FROM THREE
YEARS TO TWO YEARS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
REPEALS LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THAT ESTABLISHES AND
DEVELOPS ADMINISTRATIONS.
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
FELONY DIVERSION PILOT PROGRAM
THE AUTHORS OFFICE HAS NOTED
THAT AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE ARE FORTHCOMING WHICH MAY
CHANGE OUR POSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DELEGATES OUT
ON OF THE ROLL CALL.
I SEE NO AUTHORS I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE SOME SENATOR AUTHORS AT THIS
TIME WE ARE GOING TO READ A LOT
OF COMMOTION ON THE CAN CALENDAR.
MOTION BY MISTER CALDERON A
SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK --
AND MA'AM SURGERY WE PLEASE READ
THAT COUNTER.
IT'S BEEN 979-922-3410 FORTY SIX
ELEVEN ON NINE ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
THAT 911-240-81250.
FOUR TWELVE SIXTY ONE OF
621-305-1580. 614-511-45714
NINETY ONE FORTUNATELY WITHIN
MINUTES FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
INPUT.
TO NINETY FIVE THANK YOU AND I
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MISTER WEINER --
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE PRESENTING
ON S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO WE HAVE IT
HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO.
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK PROJECT
PROCEED SHARE COLLEAGUES ARE A
BE BRIEF US TO FORTY FORTY TWO
REQUIRES LARGE.
RETAIL FOR CHAIN PHARMACIES TO
ENSURE --
DIED --
PHARMACISTS ARE NOT LEFT ALONE --
AND THEN ANOTHER AYE STAFF
MEMBER SIX OF THE CLERK FOR
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN IS AVAILABLE
TO ASSIST.
OF THE PHARMACIST --
Y. HERE SHE IS AT WORK CAUGHT
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
AGENCIES HAVE GIVEN. FOR
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS GREATER
AND GREATER RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE DIRECT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AROUND OPIOID ADDICTION
VACCINES CONTRACEPTION ETCETERA --
HOWEVER OF PHARMACISTS ARE
PARTICULARLY IN THE LARGE CHAINS
OF FOR GOING TO LEFT ALONE FOR
HOURS OR EVEN AN ENTIRE SHIFT --
THEY THEN HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
USING THE RESTROOM --
AND PROVIDING SERVICE LINES
FORMATS THEY HAVE TO STEP ASIDE
TO PROVIDE --
HEALTH CARE SOMEONE IT'S REALLY
UNTENABLE --
AND SO --
THAT THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
ABROAD TRYING TO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
I'M JEANNE DREXLER AND I'VE BEEN
A PHARMACIST FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
STATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY TWO SO
THAT PHARMACISTS ARE PROVIDED
WITH THE MINIMUM LEVEL OF
STAFFING TO KEEP PATIENTS SAFE.
ON THIS ISSUE IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE TWO OF
MY FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF MEDICATION ERRORS.
MY SON ENDED UP IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM AND MY FATHER IN LAW I
NEVER RECUPERATED AND DIED.
THIS LAST WEEKEND THEY WERE
COMPLETELY BY MYSELF I DID THE
JOB OF THREE PEOPLE A CLERK AT
TECHNICIAN AND A PHARMACIST.
IT WAS OVERWHELMING WITH
CONSTANT INTERRUPTIONS IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT TO PERFORM MY
CLINICAL DUTIES HAVE COUNSELING
PATIENCE GIVING AND STATIONS AND
EVALUATING DRUG INTERACTIONS.
WHILE ANSWERING PHONES RUNNING
SIX COMPUTERS AND TWO CASH
REGISTERS --
PHARMACIST NEED TO BE A 100%
ACCURATE THERE IS NO ROOM FOR
ERROR.
AND FAR WERE NOW CLINICAL
PROVIDERS AND OUR PATIENTS ARE
ENTRUSTING THIS WITH THEIR LIVES.
THEY NEED OUR UNDIVIDED
ATTENTION AND DESERVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE CARE.
THANK YOU AS SPEAKERS AND SPORT.
SO FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME SONG I'M A PHARMACY IS A
FUNDS IN SUPPORT.
THING CAM.
SWEET GIRL IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE A
RESPECT ESCRIBIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT GETS OUT ON A. B..
NOW THAT GETS OUT WITHIN.
WITH THE REPUBLICAN ROLL CALL
MISTER BIGELOW VOTING NO MISTER
BROKE VOTING AYE MR FUNG WRITING
I AM IS GALLAGHER NOT.
VOTING MIGHT.
HOW ABOUT THIS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
VOTING AYE I WILL READ MISTER
BIGELOW [inaudible]
YOU'RE NOW [inaudible]
YES.
MR PEROT.
IS AN AYE MR FUNG IS AN AYE MR
GALLAGHER.
AND MISTER OBERNOLTE IS NOT.
THE BILL GETS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
KERN I THAT WAS MY PAYER INVOICE
I MY A REPUBLICAN FRUSTRATION
PIRATE VOICE MISS JACKSON.
MR -- YOU'RE
GONNA WAIVE YOUR SUSPENSE
PRESENTATION ENDS YEAH AS I AM
AND YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON SB
TWENTY SEVEN THAT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE AN A MOTION BY MISS
CREEL AND SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
VERY GOOD I WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF
THEN -- THIS
IS SB THREE TWENTY SEVEN IT
SEEKS TO CREATE A COMMONSENSE
SECURITY REQUIREMENT FOR
INTERNET CONNECTED DEVICES SUCH
AS WIRELESS ROUTERS SECURITY
CAMERA SMART CITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
BY DIRECTING MANUFACTURERS OF
SAYS TO EQUIP THEIR PRODUCT WITH
REASONABLE SECURITY FEATURES
SOMETHING YOU WOULD THINK WE
WOULD HAVE TO DO.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT MOST OF THESE --
ENTITIES SHOULD HAVE NOT BEEN
DOING SO AND WE DO LIVE IN A
BRAVE NEW WORLD.
WHERE INTERNET CONNECTED DEVICES
HAVE MOVED WELL BEYOND
TRADITIONAL DESKTOP COMPUTERS?
UNFORTUNATELY --
OUT WE NEED TO REQUIRE BECAUSE
AS I SAID WE'RE NOTSEEING THE
MOST BASIC SECURITY FEATURES.
SO THIS BILL REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS TO EQUIP THEIR
INTERNET CONNECTED DEVICES --
WITH FEATURES BASED ON THE
NATURE OF THE MACHINE IN NEWS.
AND THOSE COULD INCLUDE THINGS
HAS THE ABILITY SIMPLY TO CHANGE
THE DEFAULT PASSWORD OR DETECT
POTENTIAL HACKERS.
THIS BILL ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE IRWIN'S PARALLEL
MEASURE A. B. NINETEEN OH SIX
RECOGNIZE THE EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE OF CYBERSECURITY.
AND THEREFORE WE GIVE INDUSTRY
WIDE LATITUDE IN DETERMINING
JUST WHAT PRECISE MEASURES ARE
NEEDED FOR EACH PARTICULAR
DEVICE BUT PRODUCING AND SELLING.
OF THESE DEVICES ARE THAT PUTS
OUR PERSONAL INFORMATION IN
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AT RISK
NEEDS TO BE RELEGATED TO THE
PAST AND THAT IS THE BASIS FOR
THIS.
MEASURE THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
TECHNOLOGY HAS AND CONTINUES TO
REVOLUTIONIZE OUR LIVES BUT IT'S
UP TO US AS POLICY MAKERS TO
ENSURE THE TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT SECURITY IS NOT AN
AFTER THOUGHT BUT RATHER A KEY
COMPONENT OF THE DESIGN PROCESS
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE.
THINK YOU AND SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
DANIEL KENDO KAISER ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
PRIVACY RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE IN
SUPPORT.
I DO HAVE ANY SPEAKERS
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OPPOSES THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
PLACES CALIFORNIA INTERNET
CONNECTED DEVICE MANUFACTURERS
AT A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
WHILE PROVIDING THE MEANS FOR
NON COMPLAINT DEVICES TO ENTER
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETPLACE.
IF I MAY RESPOND TO THAT --
AYE I THINK FIRST DO YOU VERY
MUCH AND DOCTOR QUIRK
[inaudible]
TOM [inaudible]
I AM.
WHY DID YOU HAVE A SEVERAL
HUNDRED PEOPLE IS THE ENFORCER
I'M CONCERNED WE HAVE SEVERAL
HUNDRED STANDARDS AS TO WHAT
REASONABLE LAYERS?
YOU HAVE CITY ATTORNEYS --
DE A THESE AS WELL AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
WELL WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOME
FLEXIBILITY HERE BECAUSE WE END
TFSA PAID THAT THERE WILL BE
BEST PRACTICES AS WE GET PEOPLE
INTO THE ROOM.
AS WE GET THEM TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THESE --
BASIC --
STANDARDS ARE FOR SECURITY WHICH
WE ARE.
BASICALLY TELLING THEM YOU'VE
GOT TO CONSIDER --
SECURITY FEATURES AND THEY THEY
CAN BE AND SHOULD BE FRANKLY
BASED UPON THE NATURE.
THE ITEM THAT IS THAT WE THAT
NEEDS THAT SECURITY --
HOPEFULLY THERE WILL BE BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE CREATED SO
THAT WE WILL FIND COMPANIES IN
COMPLIANCE --
IT IT'S DIFFICULT TO HAVE.
ONE I WOULD THINK HIM ONE GROUP
DECIDE OR ONE ENTITY ONE
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY DECIDE WHAT'S
REASONABLE AND WHAT IS NOT
REASONABLE --
Y. DIVISION GREED THAT.
ARTISTS WILL BE VOTING FOR THE
BILL NOW WELL I'M HAPPY TO
DISCUSS THE ISSUE WITH YOU
FURTHER AGAIN THANK YOU THE
PREMISES WE'VE GOT TO GET THESE
COMPANIES TO CONSIDER BASIC
SECURITY FEATURES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THAT YOUR CLOSE NO MY I'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS
OF A OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
WE DO NOT WANT TO CREATE ANY
KIND OF A DISADVANTAGE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES WERE VERY
HAPPY TO WORK. TO HONE IN ON
WHAT THE WORD MANUFACTURE MEAN
SO THAT WE'RE NOT --
AGAIN CREATING THOSE PROBLEMS
THAT WE JUST LEARNED OF THIS
CONCERN I THINK IT'S A
LEGITIMATE ONE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
TO TO DEAL WITH THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU AND I GET OUT ON TO BE
ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
SORRY DOT YOU'RE PRESENTING AN
S. B.. NINE NINE EIGHT YES IT
ENJOYS THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATIONS APPARENTLY I'M
GETTING ALMOST INSTANTLY CONCEIT --
THAT'S A MOTION BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK AND EIGHTY SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
MORE STRINGENT WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS IN THE AFFECTS OF
WATER CONSERVATION ON REVENUE.
PUSH WATER COSTS IN RESIDENT
RESIDENTIAL WATER RATES HIGHER
ALL THE TIME.
A RISING WATER RATES ARE
RESULTING IN HIGHER DELINQUENCY
RATES ON WATER BILLS WHICH WHICH
IN TURN LEADS TO MORE WATER SHUT
OFFS.
WHILE THEY'RE CONSISTENT LIFE
WHY PROGRAMS FOR ELECTRIC GAS
AND TELEPHONE RATE PAYERS
THERE'S ONLY A PATCHWORK OF
LOCAL POLICIES FOR LOW INCOME
RATEPAYERS WHEN THEY BECOME
DELINQUENT [inaudible]
OF S. B. NINE I WOULD SET A
BASIC SET OF GROUND RULES FOR
WATER AGENCIES ON THAT ACROSS
THE STATE THERE NO MAN TO
TERRITORY.
PAYMENT WAIVERS AND NINE NINE
EIGHT IT ALL RATEPAYERS MUST
EVENTUALLY PAY THEIR BILLS.
I IT JUST PROVIDES BASIC
PROTECTIONS FOR HOUSEHOLDS WITH
VULNERABLE OCCUPANTS IT ENSURES
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER IS UP HELD A
PROTECTED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
ALEXANDER HARMED IN WITH THAT
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
EIGHT WHILE MOST CUSTOMERS NEVER
EXPERIENCE WATER SHUT OFF FOR
THE LOW INCOME AND VULNERABLE
TENANTS WE REPRESENT.
SO I SHUT OFF AND HAVE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES FOR EVERY ASPECT OF
THEIR LIVES.
THIS BILL HAS MINOR COSTS AND
INCLUDES IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS
FOR LOW INCOME AND DISABLED
RESIDENTS INCREASES TRANSPARENCY
AND THE ABILITY TO RESOLVE
DELINQUENT ACCOUNTS.
AND ENSURES RECONNECTION FEES DO
NOT POSE AN INAPPROPRIATE
BARRIER TO RESUMING WATER
SERVICE AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
A GOOD MORNING CAO JONES IS HERE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARCUS REPRESENTING FOOD
AND WATER WATCH AND SUPPORT.
DAN HOLLIS CLEAN WATER ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
HE CARES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M WENDY
WRITER BUSH WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES OR
AQUA.
BOB WAS PART OF A LARGE
COALITION OF OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE NINE EIGHT INCLUDING NOT
FOR PROFIT WATER AGENCIES
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS AND
SOME CITIES THAT PURVEY WATER.
THE COALITION REPRESENTS 90% OF
THE WATER THAT'S DELIVERED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHILE WE CONTINUE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR ACCEPTING PRIOR
AMENDMENTS TO THE LEGISLATION
THE BILL STILL PROBLEMATIC TO
OUR MEMBER AGENCIES.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE FISCAL FRONT
OR MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
SHIFTING COSTS FROM ONE SET OF
CUSTOMER RATE PAYERS TO ANOTHER --
AND THAT MAYBE IT VIOLATE PROP
TWO EIGHTEEN WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT IT ALSO MAKES THE
COST OF WATER LESS AFFORDABLE
FOR THOSE THAT SIT.
ABOVE BUT NEAR 22100% FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE CONTAINED IN THIS
BILL WE ARE CERTAIN WHAT THE
ACTUAL COSTS ARE GOING TO BE FOR
WATER DISTRICTS.
THIS UNCERTAINTY WAS UNDERSCORED
BY A RECENT LETTER SENT BY FITCH
WHICH CONDUCTS RATING REVIEWS
FOR PUBLIC WATER DISTRICTS TO
ONE OF OUR MEMBER AGENCIES UNDER
A SECTION TITLED FINANCES IN
RATES.
FITCH ASK OUR MEMBER TO PLEASE
DISCUSS NINE NINE EIGHT WHAT
WOULD BE THE IF IF THE EXPECTED
FISCAL IMPACT TO THE DISTRICT IF
IT WAS PASSED AS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO PROVIDE A
DEFINITIVE ANSWER TO THAT AND
THAT CONCERNS US RATINGS FROM
COMPANIES LIKE FUTURE IMPORTANT
AS THEY CAN IMPACT THE RATE AT
WHICH WATER DISTRICTS BORROW
FUNDING TO HELP PAY FOR LARGE
CAPITAL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
LIKE GROUND WATER SPREADING
BASINS WATER RECYCLING
FACILITIES OR ENLARGEMENT OF THE
BUT THE GROUND WATER STORAGE
RESERVOIRS FOR EXAMPLE.
WATER AGENCIES WORK HARD TO KEEP
THE COST OF WATER SERVICE DOWN
FOR ALL CUSTOMERS.
IT'S FOR THIS FISCAL REASON AND
OTHER POLICY REASONS THAT WE'VE
LAID OUT IN MULTIPLE --
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS YEAR
THAT WE CONTINUE TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB NINE AND EIGHT THINK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND JASON
AYE OCCURRED WITH IDLE STINK
OVER ROPES AND SMITH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION.
AND THE INTEREST OF TIME ON OUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
I'M SIMPLY GONNA ACCO AQUA.
BUT I DID WANT TO POINT NOW
URINALYSIS RAISES A GOOD POINT
WHICH IS THAT.
STATEWIDE DATA IS NOT AVAILABLE
ON THE NET THERE WATER SHUT OFF
BY A PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
WE WOULD TAKE THAT A STEP FATHER
FOR A FARTHER AND SAY THAT THERE
IS NOT.
DATA OR AT LEAST NOT EVIDENCE OR
DATA THAT WE HAVE SEEN RELATED
TO SHUT OFF FOR LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS --
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE SENATOR STAFF --
WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS AND
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO RESOLVE
THOSE ISSUES.
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE BILL AND
WE ALSO FURTHER AS UPSET HAVEN'T
SEEN THE EVIDENCE THAT IS
NECESSARY FOR TO TO SUPPORT THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL.
THOSE REASONS WERE ULTIMATELY A
POST THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THINK UTERINE MEMBERS JOHN SAID
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE O. TIE
WATER DISTRICT IN THE MISSING
SPRINGS WATER DISTRICT
RESPECTFULLY POST THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR RICHARD HARRIS --
ON BEHALF OF THE LIMON HANGING
IN THIS BILL WATER DISTRICT AND
PONDERED EMINENCE BUT WANTED
DISTRICT THAT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE.
MADAM CHAIR I APOLOGIZE I MISS
THE SUPPORT LINE THERESA
BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS KINDRED
I JUGGLED WHILE GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE LONG BEACH WATER DISTRICT
MODESTO IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND
THE CITY OF FRESNO ON OF
OPPOSITION.
BUT A CHAIR MEMBERS RON DAVIS ON
BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT ALSO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU KNOW I THINK OUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCES ARE.
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD AND THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ESTIMATE
MINORS OR GLOBAL COSTS HOWEVER
FINANCE KNOWS THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE.
GIVEN THAT IT MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE TO INCREASE RATES ON
OTHER CUSTOMERS ON RELATED TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THEIR SERVICE.
THANK YOU I THINK WOMEN QUESTION
AND THE BY MISCREANT MISTER
GARCIA WILL START WITH MISS CLEO.
I THINK IT'S MORE OF A COMMENT
MADAM CHAIR BUT I'VE TODAY M.
I'M INSPIRED --
I I BELIEVE IN THE TERM KNOWN AS
ME WHICH TONY WATER IS LIFE.
AND THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
FOR YOU FOR LESS HUMAN BEINGS
FOR HUMANITY.
I'M ALSO INSPIRED BY THE FACT
THAT WE'VE HEARD BILLS ON
QUALITY OF LIFE AND THE DIGNITY
OF CALIFORNIANS WHETHER IT'S I
ENSURING THAT THE HOMELESS
POPULATION HAS A PLACE TO GO
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE HOSPITAL
ENSURING THAT.
OF FOLKS DON'T GET THE LAST
MONEY INTO THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS
HE CAN OUT ENSURING THAT --
HAVE ACCESS TO WATER AS MANY
PEOPLE FACE --
LACK OF JOBS AND DIGNITY IT'S
JUST IT'S INSPIRING TO THINK
THAT WE HAVE A POSITION TO
REALLY HELP PEOPLE SO THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL UP TO US
AND FOR WORKING ON IT AND AND I
1100% UNDERSTAND THE THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION AND I
HOPE THAT WE GET TO A PLACE
WHERE.
WERE ABLE TO RESOLVE THESE
MATTERS BUT I THINK WE'RE MOVING
IN THE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
FOR CALIFORNIA SO I THINK YOU.
EPICENTER THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF
WATER AGENCIES IN OUR DISTRICT
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION
I I DO.
WANT TO WORK WITH THEM IN YOUR
OFFICE TO SEE IF WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE WHERE --
WE CAN ADDRESS MOST OF THEIR
CONCERNS I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
FORMER.
BOARD MEMBER OF THE WATER
UTILITY THE CITY THAT I
REPRESENTED BEFORE THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY.
FOUR HUNDRED SHUT OFF NOTICES
THAT WOULD GO OUT EVERY MONTH --
OF THE MAYBE THREE FOUR THOUSAND
ACCOUNTS AND OF THOSE.
FOUR HUNDRED YOU'D SAY ABOUT A
HUNDRED OF OF WHAT ACTUALLY GET
SHUT OFF AND THEN THE OTHERS YOU
KNOW WERE FOLKS THAT JUST BASED
ON TIMING OF WHEN THEY GOT PAID
WERE ABLE TO YOU KNOW PAY THEIR
UTILITY BILL ON TIME.
UP BUT IT IS --
FOR MANY PEOPLE DROP THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVING TO REALLY
DECIDE IF THEY CAN PAY A PORTION
OF THEIR WATER BILL AND OR THEIR
ELECTRICAL BILL AND IN THAT
REGION THAT I REPRESENT.
IT'S A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
DEGREES TODAY OUT THERE AND SAW
IT YOU KNOW YOU YOU DON'T HAVE A
WHOLE LOT OF OPTIONS TO BE ABLE --
TO BE WITHOUT ONE ELECTRICAL
POWER AND OR WATERED SO WE
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY I'M
HOPING THAT I CAN NOT
FACILITATING CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO GET
TO A BETTER PLACE FOR THEM AS
WELL.
THANK YOU LOOK FOR THAT ASSEMBLY.
PAST MY THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL --
I KNOW THERE WAS QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW OFTEN THIS HAPPENS AND I
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER TO THAT
BUT I KNOW THAT MY A OUR WATER
WAS MISTAKENLY SHOT OFF BECAUSE
THEY WERE TOO LOTS.
TO PROPERTIES ON ONE NOT AND IT
WAS MY NEIGHBOR WHOSE WATER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SHUT OFF BUT ON
THE INCONVENIENCE --
AND I END.
PEOPLE ARE VERY QUICK TO COME
BACK INTERNET ON BUT THE
INCONVENIENCE OF THAT COSTS ARE
FAMILY IN TRYING TO HAVE A
FAMILY OUT WITH NO RUNNING WATER
EVEN FOR I THINK IT WAS EIGHT
HOURS A NIGHT THAT WAS.
I HAD THE EXPEDITED SERVICE TO
SAY THE LEAST --
WAS IT.
A MESS IN SO WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO I THINK FOR THOSE OF US
ESPECIALLY THAT REPRESENT REALLY --
WORKING CLASS AND POOR
COMMUNITIES IS ESSENTIAL SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS I HOPE WE CAN RESOLVE THE
ISSUES WE HAVE BUT THIS IS --
I THINK IN SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE KNOW THIS IS A
PROBLEM AND SO ON IT WITH THE
NUMBERS ARE WITHOUT THE NUMBERS
IT'S SAD.
IT'S MORE THAN ANECDOTAL SO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ENCLOSED --
YOU KNOW I I JUST.
WITH THE OPPOSITION I TAKE YEAH
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE ENJOYED
WORKING WITH THAT TO THE VERY
FIRST MEETING WE HAD ON THIS --
YOU KNOW OVER THE SENATE WE HAVE
THEM OUT THE DOOR ALL THE WAY
AROUND THE WHOLE WAY IN TERMS OF
OPPOSITION WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
GET SO MANY PEOPLE --
OFF THIS GROUPS.
THE OUTSTANDING JOB OF MAKING
SURE THAT THESE.
POOR PEOPLE DO NOT FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS BUT NOT ALL OF THEM
THERE'S A LOT AREAS WHERE THEY
FALL SHORT THIS PROVIDES AT
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK.
AND I HOPE THEY'RE RIGHT.
THIS IS TO ME THAT THIS IS TO
MINIMIZE BUT IF EVEN.
ONE LOW INCOME FAMILY A PREGNANT
WOMAN OR A SENIOR ON HOSPICE HAS
THEIR WATER TURNED OFF THAT'S
ONE OR TWO TOO MANY THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG NOT
VOTING MISTER GALLAGHER.
I THINK YOU MISTER STERN.
MR STERN YOUR BE PRESENT ON SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
YES WHY DON'T WE HAVE A MOTION
BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO.
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THIS STATE
HAVE ENHANCED DISCLOSURE FOR
WHAT CHEMICALS ARE BEING PUMPED
UNDERGROUND IN NATURAL GAS
STORAGE FIELDS IF IF IF IT'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR FRACKING IT'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE NATURAL GAS
INDUSTRY --
RESPECT THE S. RIVAL.
IT'S BEEN.
MOVED AND SECONDED AND MOVED
AGAIN -- ANY
SUPPORTERS.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
LIKE IT'S OUT ON A PEOPLE CALLED
THINK YOU.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS WHO
WANT TO PRESENT IT WOULD BE A
SHAME TO MISS THIS MEETING
BECAUSE YOU DON'T GET ANOTHER
TALK THIS YEAR.
THAT BEING SAID WE WILL HAVE A
READ OUT THE BILLS THAT ARE
BEING MOVED TO SUSPENSE WHERE
PRESENTATION HAS BEEN WAIVED.
S. B. TEN SIXTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
WHEN. 681-832-12220.
725-289-21550 SIX I NEVER TWENTY
FOUR ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN ANOTHER
551-182-1215 WATT EIGHTY FOURTH.
FOR NINETY FOUR THIRTEEN OH NINE
PORTS YOU KNOW THREE FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN EIGHTY AND
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THANK YOU.
MISTER ALAN SMART MAN.
I JUST THAT HAVE IT.
IT'S A CENTER LARA. TO GET HERE
FIRST HOW LIGHT HOUSE SENATOR
LARA NEEDS TO SPEND SOME MORE
TIME IN THE GYM THAT.
ALLEN SP SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
A SECOND BY MISS CREEL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROCEED QUICKLY.
YES THIS INCORPORATES EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL PRINCIPLES AND
CONCEPTS IN THE FUTURE CORE
CURRICULUM UPDATES BY HOW WE
REINFORCE MISTAKES CAN IN TURN
VIOLENTLY LITERATE POPULATION.
I THEIR MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
COSTS FOR BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CAL RECYCLING WE HAVE.
I STEVE BAKER HERE ON BEHALF OF
TEN STRANDS.
WE NOW HAVE TO MOTIONS IN TWO
SECONDS.
EVEN HARDER WAS THEIR GREATNESS
OF SUITS ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR TEN STRANDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
TERRACE APARTMENTS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL MACLEAN'S HE'S LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
FINANCES OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE EXISTING RD AUTHORIZES
COLORS LIKE WILL TO INCORPORATE
PROVISIONS OUTLINED IN THIS
BONTA CURRENT PRACTICES
ADDITIONALLY CHANGES PROPOSED IN
THE SPORT DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING EFFORTS.
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION HAS
ALREADY ADOPTED ENVIRONMENTAL
PRINCIPLES IN THIS MOST RECENT
CURRICULUM UPDATE.
THANK YOU CHUCK CLOSE.
OUR OUR SERVE AS A VOTE IF IF
PEOPLE DO YOU WANT ME TO
RESPONSIBLY CONCERT AND HAVE IT
DO.
THANK YOU THIS BILL PASSES WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING MISTER
BRODY NO THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU.
SENATOR LARA OF COURSE I WAS
JOKING I NAY BEEN REALLY BUSY
AND CONTINUING TO WORK OUT.
SAN LARA YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON
SB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO UMBEL
[inaudible]
AT A SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW.
BUT THAT'S WHY I DON'T THINK
HE'LL SUPPORTERS.
KAREN WEIGHING IN I ON BEHALF OF
THE POTS ARE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THINK ARE VERY FAIR
AUTHOR FOR THE DEALT VERY PART
WE NEED THE DATA ASK HER ABOUT
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS ANY
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE DISPATCH
THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN COST OF
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GO INTO THE SHARON'S FUND.
FOR BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WE EXPECT ANY
COST ME MINOR AN OBSERVABLE.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE NEED A COUPLE
AUTHORS I THINK WE READ OUT S.
B. TEN BUT I THINK.
STERN HERTZBERG WAS GOING TO
PRESENT ON IT SO HE STOLE ONE
STILL HE SHOULD COME --
SENATOR NGUYEN WANTED TO PRESENT
A HERE WE I SEE HER [inaudible]
GATHERING.
FOLKS OUTSIDE ANYTHING MISS
MCGUIRE STILL HAS A BILL.
CENTER WHEN ARE WE READY HERE
[inaudible]
THAT'S OKAY.
THE TRAIN GETS OF TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN GET THE
FOLKS IN HERE. TO SPEAK OR WRITE
US WHERE ARE WE HAVING A PROM
BRINGING THEM AND ALTHOUGH.
I'M NOT REALLY SURE WHICH I
FIGURED HOW HOPE.
OF WHICH WAY WHICH DOOR THEY'RE
COMING IN [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
WELL MY SPEAKERS AROUND YEAH CAN
YOU WAITING A COUPLE MINUTES
MADAM CHAIR I CAN'T I CAN'T I
MEAN MISTER MCGUIRE IF POSSIBLE
ARE MISTER HERTZBERG ALL NIGHT
YOU PRAY DON'T WANT HIM TO GO
FIRST -- I
MEAN.
THE MINIMUM JUST GIVE MY YET
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO GET.
WE'RE SORRY I DON'T KNOW THERE'S
BUT IN THE FOLKS IN [inaudible]
I HATE.
CAN YOU START YOUR PRESENTATION
OUT THE MAN.
YES I I HAVE MY SPEAKERS TO THAT
AYE THEY'RE NOT THERE IN THE
OTHER ROOM.
OKAY.
IS THEIR PROBLEM WHERE.
BRINGING FOLKS AND THERE'S ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
I UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS THE OTHER SPEAKERS?
NO I DEFICIT IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE I WANT TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION NOT TO
THIS BILL OR TO SP --
TEN AT THIS TIME BECAUSE THEY
CAN UP THE MICROPHONE AND
REGISTER THAT'S PORTER
OPPOSITION TO ANY SUSPENSE BILL
THAT WAS WAVED.
JUST YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOUR POSITION PLEASE.
WHERE TAKE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT?
CENTER WHEN WHILE AWAITING.
THERESA BURKE* ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
FOUR WIECKOWSKI.
TREES APARTMENTS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL THE ALAMEDA COUNTY --
WATER ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY APOLOGIZED
AND CLEANS HIS LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
ONE SIX EIGHT WITKOWSKI --
S. B. FOR A FIFTY TO GLAZER ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN THESE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT
AND S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
PORTANTINO ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY.
AND THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK HIM.
ANYBODY ELSE WHEN REGISTER
SUPPORT GUY HAD COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE IF THIS IS ANY --
OF THE SUSPENSE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN WAIVED IT'S TO TO OPPOSE S.
B. TAN.
OKAY EXCEPT S. B. TEN AND THOUGH
THE ONE I DO BELIEVE THERE STILL
BE A PRESENTATION THAT THAT WAS
A MISTAKE BUT THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PLUG INS OFFICE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
IRVINE CAMINO ENTRUSTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY SIX BELL.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY
OF THE SUSPENSE SPELLS EXCEPT S.
B. EIGHT NINETY FIVE OR S. B..
TEN ALRIGHT I THINK WITHOUT.
SENATOR WHEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU -- TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN OUR VICE
CHAIRMAN AS WELL.
I AM HONORED TO PRESENT SP.
EIGHT NINE FIVE S. B. EIGHT NINE
FIVE X. STATUS IS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST MODEL CURRICULUM ON THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE AND
ALSO THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE
[inaudible]
EXPERIENCE.
IT WILL EXPAND UPON THE CURRENT
CURRICULUM ON THE VIETNAM WAR
AIR BY INCORPORATING THE VOICES
OF THOSE WHO LIVE.
DURING THIS TIME INCLUDING THE
TESTIMONIES OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM ARMED FORCES
AND THE VIETNAMESE BOAT PEOPLE.
S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE STATE'S FIRST
MODEL CURRICULUM ON THE COMMODE
IN GENOCIDE.
AND THE LIKE AND LIKE THE
EFFORTS TO MORE ICE THE
VIETNAMESE REFUGEE EXPERIENCE.
THIS BILL WILL CONDUCT THE
STORIES OF MILLIONS OF CAMBODIAN.
GENOCIDE VICTIMS AS WELL.
AS A FIRST HAND ACCOUNTS OF
INDIVIDUAL WHO LIVED DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR.
AND THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE AS
ARE LOST TO TIME.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE A
CONSCIOUS CONSCIOUS.
EFFORT TO PRESERVE THEIR STORIES
FOR EDUCATIONAL BENEFIT.
OF OUR CHILDREN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I INTRODUCED THIS BILL IN
JANUARY AND SINCE THEN S. B.
EIGHT NINE FIVE HAS GONE AWRY
SPREAD SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
OVER THE COURSE OF THREE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON THE SENATE
SIDE AND THE SUMMIT EDUCATION.
NEARLY OVER SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS HAVE COME TO
SACRAMENTO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
NOT INCLUDE THOSE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY ADDITIONAL WE ALSO RECEIVE
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE SUBMITTED
SIGNED PETITIONS.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
MANY OF WHOM ARE REFUGEES
THEMSELVES.
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE. TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE HISTORY OF THE VIETNAM
WAR ERA AND A COMMODIOUS
GENOCIDE THIS COMPREHENSIVE
CURRICULUM WERE SERVED. TO HELP
OUR CHILDREN UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
HISTORY SHAPES OUR WERE VIEW.
I MONITOR HAVE SENATE A LOTTA.
AS A JOINT AUTHOR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KARA AND QUICKSILVER AS
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
TODAY I'M PRIVILEGED TO HAVE
STEAM GASES AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK TO
THE VALUE OF S. B. --
EIGHT NINE FIVE INTRODUCED THEM
BUT THE NOMINAL YIELD THE TIME
OVER TO ASSEMBLYMAN KARA FIRST --
WE'VE GOT DEAL QUINN WHEN.
CHAIR OF THE VIETNAMESE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CHAIRWOMAN OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
ASSOCIATION THE VIETNAMESE
LANGUAGE AND CULTURE.
SCHOOLS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE SINNED EACH RAN.
A UNITED STATE NAVY VETERAN AND
VICE CHAIR OF THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE DANG KIM CHANNEL.
PRESIDENT OF THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY OF SAN DIEGO.
WE ALSO HAVE DR ROSS ME.
COUNCILMAN.
A HEALTH PROFESSIONAL UPHELD
PROFESSOR A PROFESSOR WITHIN THE
COME MODI'IN COMMUNITY.
AT THIS TIME I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
ASSEMBLYMAN KARA TO SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE OUR OUR RULES
ARE TWO SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES
EACH AND FLEXIBLE IF YOU WANT
FOR SPEAKERS ITS MINUTE EACH BUT
WERE -- I
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE IN SUPPORT SUCH AS WE MAKE
SURE WE NOW ON SPEAKERS WHERE --
YOU GET FOUR MINUTES PART OF
TOTAL WILL WHAT WILL MAKE IT
VERY SHORT MAIN CARE AND IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE MISTER KALRA WHO
IS JUST DECIDED TO GRACE US.
WITH HIS PRESENCE BECAUSE WE
NEED MORE SPEAKERS.
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU AS WELL
MADAM CHAIR I JUST.
IT'S IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE --
WANT TO THANK YOU IN THE MEMBERS
OF OF FOR INDULGING US ON AND
WHAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
CERTAINLY --
FOR MY COMMUNITY --
AND I KNOWFOR MANY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
PRODUCT A CO PRESENT SP EIGHT
NINETY FIVE REQUIRED
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP A MODEL CURRICULUM ON
THE VERY IMPORTANT TOPICS.
AND THAT MEANS AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE AND THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE.
THERE OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
THOUSAND IT MEANS AMERICANS
RESIDING IN SAN JOSE ALONE
MAKING AT THE CITY.
MAKING THE CITY HOME THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY OF ENEMIES AMERICANS
OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM --
MANY OF THEM ARE HERE TODAY AND
IN MY CAPACITY AS REPRESENTATIVE.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBER OF SAN JOSE
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO WITNESS OF THE
SOLIDARITY STRENGTH AND
RESILIENCE LIVING MEANS PEOPLE
AND CULTURE.
THE VIETNAM WAR TORE APART A
COUNTRY WHOSE PEOPLE ARE LEFT
LEAN FOR POLITICAL PERSECUTION.
THOSE REFUGEES OF SENSE
RECREATED THEIR LIVES IN AMERICA
SUCCEEDING IN BUSINESS AND
EDUCATION TO BUILD PIPELINES ARE
FUTURE AMERICANS BUT THEY HAVE
NEVER FORGOTTEN --
THEIR COUNTRY AND NEVER
FORGOTTEN THE EXPERIENCES OF
FIGHTING FOR FREEDOM.
THE CAMARO ROUGE IS ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST PERIODS IN HISTORY
CURRENTLY GLOSSED OVER AND
TEXTBOOKS.
LED BY POL POT THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE WIPED OUT ANY
INDIVIDUAL DEEMED A POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
TEMPLES ARE BURNED BOOKS WERE
OUTLAWED AND ABOUT ONE QUARTER
OF THE COUNTRY'S POPULATION WAS
MURDERED.
STILL THE PEOPLE PERSISTED AND
FOUND THEIR WAY TO AMERICAN
SHORES FOR A BETTER LIFE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT LEGISLATION
THAT INCREASES THE AWARENESS OF
AND APPRECIATION FOR OUR REFUGEE
AND IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS BUT
CERTAINLY WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT A
IMMIGRANT SOME ASIAN OF OF ASIAN
AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS.
I LIKE MYSELF --
THAT COME HERE AND GET EDUCATED --
IN THE AMERICAN EDUCATION SYSTEM
STORIES ARE NOT TOLD THESE ARE
STORIES OF OUR NEIGHBORS OF OUR
FRIENDS AND IN MANY CASES FAMILY
MEMBERS --
SO LET US EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN
ABOUT THE REALITIES IN TRAUMA
PAST AND PRESENT.
OF OUR BIG MUSIC CAN BE
COLLODION AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS THE RESILIENCE OF
THESE COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S NO BETTER WAY TO COME
BACK THESE HISTORICAL ATROCITIES
AND MISPERCEPTIONS OF THEM.
AS WELL AS THE STRUGGLES TO
OVERCOME THEM --
WITH EDUCATION UNDERSTANDING AND
COMPASSION PUT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I DON'T
KNOW I THINK THE SENATOR FOR
AUTHORING [inaudible]
THANK YOUNG.
WILL PROCEED WITH YOUR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
PRESIDENT OF THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY OP SANTIAGO.
I'M HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT MY
COMMUNITY SUPPORTING THE S. B..
EIGHT NINE FIVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE LACK
JUST COMMUNITY OFF THE OVERSEAS
VIETNAMESE.
REFUGEES OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM.
INSTEAD YOU WILL COUNTY THE
POPULATION OF ASIAN.
CREATURES COMBINATION UP MORE
ALLOW VIETNAMESE AND CAMBODIA.
IS. ELEVEN POINT 5% IN TWO
THOUSAND ASIAN IN. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN FOR MORE THAN FOUR
DECADES VIETNAMESE AMERICANS WHO
SETTLED IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE SOCIAL.
CULTURAL AND COMICS UP THE STATE.
THE S. B..
EIGHT NINE FIVE WILL HELP BUILD
A BRIDGE BETWEEN GENERATIONS OF
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS.
THAT WOULD ALSO ALLOW ONLY
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS THE ABILITY
TO LEARN ABOUT THEIR CLASSMATES
FROM VIETNAM.
AND CAMBODIA WHO ARE HERE WITH
THE FAMILY POST VIETNAM WAR.
THE YOUNG NEED THEIR OWN
IDENTITY CONFIDENCE AND
EDUCATION UP HOW.
OUR HISTORY SHAPES OUR WORK VIEW.
HISTORY REMAINS UNCHANGED.
THE BOOK PEOPLE THE SUCKERS
CRISIS OFF SOUTH VIETNAMESE
SOLDIERS AND MORE THAN FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND UP U. S..
SERVICE MEMBERS FOR FREEDOM
DEMOCRACY AND HUMIDITY.
ARE THE TRUTH.
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
OUR DEAR HONORABLE CONGRESSMAN
AND CONGRESSWOMAN THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RACKS MUKASA MEN.
AND I SUPPORT SB.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE I AM AN
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR.
AS SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE AND
A HEALTH PROFESSIONAL HUMAN
RIGHTS ADVOCATE.
AND I SPENT MOST OF MY STUDY AND
CAREER.
STUDYING IN PARKS AT THE
COMPUTER GENOCIDES ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF THE
COMPUTING COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
MY PARENTS ARE SURVIVORS OF THE
COMPLETED GENOCIDE.
AND I WAS BORN IN THE REFUGEE
CAMP AND IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES WHEN I WAS.
NINE THE GENOCIDE DEEPLY IMPACT
THE SOCIAL FABRIC.
AT THE COMPUTER SOCIETY HERE AND
ABROAD AND IT NEEDS TO BE
EXPLORED.
THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS ARE NOT DISCUSS
ABOUT IN OUR SCHOOLS.
LEAVING MANY CAMBODIAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS TEACHERS HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS UNABLE TO FULLY
COMPREHEND THE IMPACT THAT IT
HOUSE ON OUR MENTAL HEALTH
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
SO I URGE YOU TODAY TO PLEASE
SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT NINETY FIVE
SO THAT YOUNG PEOPLE.
OUR YOUNG ON THE NEED THE NEXT
GENERATION.
CAN LEARN AND UNDERSTAND ABOUT
THE COMPUTING GENOCIDES AND SEE
THEIR HISTORY REFLECTED IN OUR
SCHOOLS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MISS THE VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME.
SPEAK TODAY SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT POINT.
FIVE MY NAME IS GOING QUITE YOU
QUEEN IMUS US CITIZEN AND A
SCHOOL TEACHER AT THE LOCAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN KIND OF
COLORFUL OFFERED TWENTY FOUR
YEARS.
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AT THE
AGE OF FOURTEEN I FLED VIETNAM
WITH MY FAMILY IN SEARCH OF
FREEDOM AND ESCAPE COMMUNIST.
PARTY.
I NOW LIVE WITH MY HAS BEEN AND
ME TO CHILDREN IN ORANGE COUNTY
FOR ME UNITED STATES HAS OPENED
ITS ARMS TO EMBRACE MY FAMILY.
TODAY WITH FIRST CAME TO YOUR
ENDS COUNTY CALIFORNIA.
I SAID TODAY TO MAKE ONLY ONE
REQUEST PLEASE PASS THE S. B.
EIGHT FIVE FIVE BILL SO WE CAN
BUILD THE CURRICULUM TO TEACH
STUDENTS.
NOT ONLY IN THE SOUTH CALIFORNIA
ABOUT TO TO HISTORY OF VIETNAM
WAR THE VIETNAM WAR IS TAUGHT IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY POINT.
WHY I WANT TO GIVE EXAMPLE OF
THREE GROUPS OF STUDENTS WHO I
BELIEVE WILL BENEFIT FROM S. B.
EIGHT BY?
FIVE THE FIRST GROUP STUDENTS
ARE NOT INFORMED OF THAT PACKAGE
HISTORY OF VIETNAM IN THE
CURRENT HISTORY CLASSES. THREE
YEARS AGO I WAS TEACHING WHEN A
NON VIETNAMESE STUDENTS CAME UP
TO ME AND TOLD ME THAT HE REALLY
AT MY HOCHI MINH.
I WAS SHOCKED AND VERY SAD.
I WAS SHOCKED BECAUSE I GREW UP
TO LET THAT PUT YOU CAN WAS A
MAN WHO FRONTLINE HORRIBLE ACTS
OF VIOLENCE LIKE SAILING AMOUNT
TO BUILD.
THAT RESULTED IN MILLIONS OF
FAMILIES X. SCAPIN THEIR
HOMELAND TO SEEK PEACE FREEDOM
AND DEMOCRACY.
LATER I FOUND OUT THAT MY
STUDENTS WERE LED TO BELIEVE
WHAT SHE MEANT WAS A HERO
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE LEARNED IN
HISTORY CLASS WHICH LACKS
ADEQUATE DETAILS IN ACCOUNTS.
THAT APPROPRIATE DEPICT THE
EVENTS OF THE VIETNAM WAR AND
POST VIETNAM WAR ERA.
SECOND ANOTHER INCIDENTS IN MY
ONE OF MY STUDENTS VIETNAMESE
CLASS I ASKED THE STUDENTS IF
THEY KNEW THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
PAPER THIRTIETH. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ONE STUDENT JUST
ARRIVED TO U. S. RECENTLY SAID
THAT ABLE THIRTY FOUR THIRTIETH
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WAS TO
DATE BUT SOUTH VIETNAM WAS
LIBERATED.
WHEN I HEARD BUT MY HEART DROP?
BECAUSE TO BE PICKED DAY WAS
TODAY BUT MY HOME WAS TAKING
AWAY FROM ME.
AND FORCED MY FAMILY TO LEAVE
HOW PUBLIC.
SO WE CAN SURVIVE.
THEY ARE AT THE STUDENT TO SEE
IF HE WAS JOKING.
BUT HE WAS COMPLETELY SERIOUS.
I DID TOOK A TYPE WITH HIM TO
EXPLAIN THE DIFFERENT MEANING
BETWEEN THE COUNTRY LIBERATED
PEDAL LOOSING COUNTRY.
THIRD.
WHEN DAY MICE MY DAUGHTER?
BORN AND RAISED IN THE UNITED
STATE PASSED MY HAS SPENT. TO
POKE A COMMUNITY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS TO PARTICIPATE
IN A HISTORY PROJECT FOR HER
VIETNAMESE CULTURE CLASS THAT
YOU SEE I IN WHICH SHE WAS ASKED
TO INTERVIEW AND RECORD OF
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THAT JOURNEY.
FROM VIETNAM TO STATES HE WAS
SURPRISED BECAUSE HE HAS ALWAYS
THOUGHT SHE KNEW.
SO THROUGH THIS PROJECT SHE
LEARNED TO DEATH AND ACTIVE THE
DIFFICULTIES HER FATHER'S.
THAT SHE HAD MADE.
NEVER LEARNED HAD NOT BEEN FOR
HER TO REQUIRED FOR THIS PROJECT.
THEREFORE I BELIEVE TEACHING THE
ATLEAST HISTORY OF THE VIETNAM
WAR WITH THE VOICES OF THE
PERFORMER REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM
SOLDIER AND THE VIETNAMESE
REFUGEE AND THE BOOK PEOPLE I
INCLUDED WILL HELP CALIFORNIANS
STUDENTS UNDERSTAND.
THE STRUGGLES OF THE VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES WHO ARE NOW A BIG
CONTRIBUTOR TO NOT ONLY
CALIFORNIA BUT TO THE UNITED
STATES AS A WHOLE.
I BELIEF THAT THE HISTORY
TEACHERS SHOULD BE EQUIPPED WITH
THE NECESSARY TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TWO APPROPRIATE
EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS.
THE CURRENT HISTORY VIETNAM HAS
NOT BEEN TAUGHT TO INCLUDE TO
PROSPECTIVE FOR THE VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES OR SOLDIERS OF THE
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM.
BUT ONLY FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF VIETNAM
AND THE U. S..
THEREFORE I BELIEVE THAT THIS
CLASS SHOULD BE BENEFIT GOAL
THAT IS WILL TEACH THE TRUE
STORY OF THE VIETNAM WAR FOR THE
PPE CLUB ALL PROSPECTIVE.
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART AS A
PROUD VIETNAMESE AMERICAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I THINK IT
WE'VE SURPASSED SEVEN MINUTES
NOW AND I AM A SUCKER AND I'M
GONNA ASSUME THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THAT SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO. FOR EIGHT MINUTES
AND WE'RE JUST GONNA TAKE THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE TO COMPLETE THIS
PRESENTATION YES MA'AM --
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR BY
CHAIR.
AS OF MID ITS INVESTMENT I SUB
FIVE YOU ASKED WE WOULD THAT
NAVY AND WHITE DE INACTIVE.
CURRENTLY I WORK FOR THE PUBLIC
UP DEFENSE TO SUPPORT ON A
MILITARY FANTASY.
DOING WEEKEND I VOLUNTEER TO BE
A PRINCIPAL LAW SCHOOL TOP ONE
AND TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS TO
TEACH THE STUDENT ABOUT IN A
MEETING WITH AND CULTURE.
HALF THE DEFAULTING ON IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE NEARLY TWO
MILLION VIETNAMESE MY
GRANDPARENTS FAMILY INCLUDED.
HAVE RISKED THEIR LIVES ESCAPING.
IN SMALL BOOK DAY SKIP A
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT.
NAY FAKE GRUESOME STOMPED IN THE
OPEN SEA AND APPROVED A PILOT.
THEY CAN HEAR WHAT AND TO HAND
IT.
MONTH WITH NO CLOTHES ON THEIR
BACK.
HOOKED BROKEN.
AND PUTTING LINKS.
DOT COM WILL BE KEY.
BEGINNING CUT US THE VALUE OF
HOT LOOKING.
AND ASSEMBLY FIVE LESSON.
GIVING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND DID A QUICK NAY SENT UP
AMERICA.
MANY BECAME SCIENTIST JOHN DID
YOU AT PASSPORT.
AND SACRIFICE TO PROTECT OUR NEW
HOME [inaudible]
YES.
MANY NEW ONE AND NOT A FEW S.
SEASON HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE THOUGHT
DOES LOOK UP THE BOOK PEOPLE.
WANT TO GIVE ME OF WHAT A
COMPANY CAN PHAM ETCETERA.
WE DEATH WHILE SINCERELY ASK
VULNERABLE SENATOR AND THIS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO PASS
THAT BILL.
AND BRING IT TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SO THAT MIDDLE PART UP
DOES HISTORY AND HERITAGE.
CAN BE LEARNED BY LAWSUIT AND
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
THANK YOU AND MAY GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA ASK AND
THINK YOU.
THOSE FOLKS WHO.
ARE HERE AND I KNOW YOU'VE
TRAVELED FAR AND I KNOW YOU'RE
NOT PAID TO BE HERE SO.
I TRY TO BE LENIENT BUT I SEE
PAPERS SOME PEOPLE'S HANDS SO --
I'M GONNA TRY TO ASK.
AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM AND THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE IS THAT OKAY YES
MANAGER THE PAPER THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY STATES THAT OUT THERE.
IN VIETNAMESE AND IN ENGLISH SO
YOU HAVE SOME FOLKS WHO SAY IT
IN ENGLISH AND SOME FOLKS WHO
SCIENCE.
IT'S HARDLY GET WITH THAT AND WE
DON'T NEED TO KNOW THE BILL
NUMBER SO IF YOU GET CONFUSED WE
KNOW WHAT BILL WERE ON BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT HAPPENS A LOT
WHEN.
WHEN WE WHEN WE HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COME AND SPEAK SO I
THINK YOU?
YOU MAY PROCEED YOUR NAME AND
WHERE YOU'RE FROM THE SPORT THE
BILL GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STRONG VOTE.
ADVICE CHAIR OF THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY YOU NOT TURNED
CALIFORNIA.
WE SUPPORT NAUSEOUS THE ACT BE.
AETNA FIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
<c.cyan>ENTLEMEN MY NAME HORTON WE AND</c>
I AM.
A MY WILL CLOUT THAT THE LOW THE
ENGINEER IN THE DAM.
GRAZING AND AND I HAVE RESIGNED
IN THEM OR AND COUNTY I CAME
HERE TO SUPPORT YOU ASKED ME.
EIGHT MIFI --
BECAUSE OKAY I HATE THAT'S
THAT'S IT JUST THAT YOU SUPPORT
THANK YOU KNOW.
GOOD MONDAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
I MY NAME IS EVELYN PAY HER CAL
I AM HOME --
SOMETIME NOT YOU CALIFORNIA I'M
LIVE ASIA AND I AM SUPPORT.
S. B. A NINE FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NO NO DOT LEE BILLION DONE
BOSCO YET REMAINED UNITED.
AND I LEAVE SOMETIME NOT
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT SHOULD FALL [inaudible]
IT BE.
IT KNIFE I THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME RIVER YOU CAN MEASURE
ALL VIETNAMESE MARINE CALL HAD
COME HERE FROM CALIFORNIA AYE TO
POKE THROUGH AT BE A NINE FIVE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
LORETTA LYNN [inaudible]
GOOD JOB THOUGH SOME ARE YOU
TEMPO WEAPON DUH GONE AND GOT
THE THOSE WHO MOCK --
LET ME.
DIDN'T FIND ENOUGH.
COME ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVE TRIED MY BEST.
HI MY NAME IS HOW THEN AND NOW
AND DIRECTOR OF VIETNAM AM RADIO
IN SAN JOSE.
I A M. RADIO STATION DEVOTED TO
THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY AND
TODAY I'M COMING TO SACRAMENTO
TO PLEAD OUR CASE IN FRONT OF
THE APPROPRIATION.
COMMITTEE REGARDING SB EIGHT
NINE FINE.
WHEN THEY HE'S OUT WINDOWS DOORS
THANK YOU THAT'S IT TO ACT
UNFORTUNATELY NOW JUST HER NAME
AND WHO YOU REPRESENT OR WHERE
YOU'RE FROM AND YOUR SUPPORT?
AND THEN MAYES AYE PLEASE THAT
SOME ROADS THEY THOUGHT THE
LATTER RUNS DOWN THE AYE AYE AND
SO FAR S. B. F. KNIFE FURRY.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
MY NAME IS THOMAS FARM.
I COME FROM GOT THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ORANG COUNTY [inaudible]
I SUPPORT.
S. B. A KNIFE I THANK YOU.
BILLION GENTLEMAN AT MY NAME IS
ANTHONY FAMILY I'M PALM PILOT TO
BUY THEIR SULTAN CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM SUPPORT S. B..
A PIPE I WHAT MORE MONNING LADY
AND GENTLEMAN.
MY NAME HARRY WHERE RESIDING IN
SOMEBODY NO.
I SAW PAUL.
S. B. F. NIGH.
FIVE GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
MY NAME IS A LITTLE JAN I LIVE
IN.
CP UP LESS INTO.
AND IT CONSULTANT KILEY CARDIAC.
I GOT HERE DOES A LOT
[inaudible]
S. B..
A KNIFE I THINK ILL THAT ABOUT
STINKIN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME HIGH GROUND.
I'D GONE FROM --
SHOWERS DAY I SUPPORT.
THE BE A NINETY FIVE THEN TAKE
YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
RECENTLY I LIVE WE DID MATTER
YOU GOT THEY I'M COLEMAN YEAH I
SUPPOSE.
I IT BE A KNIFE I PAYING DO.
MY NAME IS HE HAD RUINED.
A I'M THE TRAYS OR OF THE OVER
THIS WOMAN ASSOCIATION IT
BROUGHT CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO REYES A DEN OF SAN JOSE
WE CAME OVER HERE TO SUPPORT THE
S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME
THE SAME ALL.
I AM THE NIGERIAN DOT ON NO TWO
AND DONE DON'T OPINION WHOLE
GAMBIT KNUCKLE HIGH SUPPLEMENTAL.
I'M HERE FOR SUPPORT THAT'S BE
BLUNTED NAM THEY GIVE
[inaudible]
YOUNG.
MY NAME DIEM DOWN I AM A MEMBER
OF OPUS A VIETNAMESE WOMAN
ASSOCIATION IN SAN JOSE --
ICON YET THOSE PAKSA S. B. EIGHT
KNIFE I GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
I AM PM PROGRAM LEAP IN SET UP
WELL MUGGING DEBATE.
ACADEMIC YEAH TO BLOCK A S. B. A
MAGPIE WELL THEN YOU CAN GET
[inaudible]
MY MAIN.
I AM NOT OUTWEIGH OF MARIA.
I LEYVA IS HOLIDAY.
SOME DON'T ACT OUT A I SEE BOX
[inaudible]
AND AT MAY ATTY I'VE AT NIGHT
PAT.
ADD IT UP.
HI MY NAME IS ON TO REALLY.
I AM AM FROM SAN JOSE --
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WELL S. B. AT
EIGHT KNIFE FRY THE ON THE THING
I WISH THAT YOU KNOW THIS BILL
WAS INTRODUCED. THIRTY NINE
YEARS AGO SO MY SOUND LONG LIST
THIS OPPORTUNITY THINK THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WHO ALWAYS JUNE RIGHT?
THERE BE.
I'VE.
EVER HAD.
YEAH THAT'LL TEACH NAM
[inaudible]
COME ON MY NAME IS LEANN AND AND
WE COME FROM THAT.
PAYING FOAMY PDF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE OF MOZILLA.
AND THE DAMN TEAM THEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
KIM.
MY NAME ISN'T GALLEY AND COME
FROM.
COMPLEMENT SAN DIEGO CD COMING
HERE TO STOP PAUL.
S. B. A NINETY FINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SETTLED THEM DOWN.
I LIVE IN DEL WESTMAN THE ORANGE
COUNTY.
AYE SEBAB.
S. B. EIGHT KNIFE I THANK YOU.
MY NAME MY NEW.
I LIVE SAN JOSE ICE BOCK MISSED
ME A KNIFE I THINK YOU.
WOOD MONNING THOUGH I DID NOT
BACK.
WHO DO HOPE YOU KNOW IF IF NAM
HANG LIKE KILEY?
HOMEMADE IN A TO SUPPORT. ONE
MEET RICK AP DAMN GENOME.
MY NAME IS SET PHAM.
OF PRESIDENT UP LOUD VIETNAMESE
SO MEDIC THAT --
I CANNOT TURN CALIFORNIA AYE
SAPULPA.
S. B.. EIGHT KNIFE I GOOD
MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
I'M A PHARMACIST THE PRESIDENT
OF THE AND THE FAMILY IF YOU
KNOW ME SO SO THEY SON.
FROM PALMDALE I SUPPORT HIGH
SPEED IT MY FIVE THANK YOU.
THOUGH DON'T THE ENTIRE GLOBAL
HOPEFUL MAYBE NOTHING WHERE THE
FUN YAK THE NOTE THEY CAN BOTH
CALIFORNIA.
DISHING THE WILL CALL YOU LOOK
SB AND PICKING THEM THEM.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MENOS AND
MY PHONE.
CORONA SO BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM OF WHY [inaudible]
PRINCIPLE OF HOME BAND CHO CHOSE
SANTA [inaudible]
I SUPPORT.
S. B. NIGHT.
SORRY A NIGHT WHAT I NAY FAR.
SO I THINK.
HI GOOD MORNING CHRISTIAN NGUYEN
FROM WESTMINSTER PAUL THEY'RE OF
HAWAIIAN CULTURAL CENTER
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN MY NAME IS MY NEW IN.
I LIVING AND SANTANA CD SOUND
AND CALIFORNIA.
I SUPPORT.
AND S. B. IT NINE FINE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
I AM MY VICTORIA LAWYER THREE
FUJI.
AND CHAPTER VVA I SAID WHEN I I
TO GATHER.
EYES SABAH.
AND AT THE I NOW I FIVE I THINK
YOU'RE READY BUT THAT IS SENATE
THOSE SENATE.
AND OLD PEOPLE SIGH AND SWAP IT
BE [inaudible]
A A KNIFE FIGHT.
BECAUSE I ONE FOOT OUT WE CAN
MAKE A HIT OF THAT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AGAIN.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY DANG
LEAVING IN LOS ANGELES OUT IN
CALIFORNIA I'M A CO TEACHER AT
LAWNDALE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I SAW PART D. S. B. A KNIFE I
THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANYBODY MY NAME
SAID NAY I SIP HOT [inaudible]
THAT BE [inaudible]
AT LIVE BY TED YOU SO MUCH.
FOLLOW ALONG JUNE AFFECTED THE
OFFERING THAT THEY THOSE IN THE
MALL YOU [inaudible]
AT BAY [inaudible]
PLATINUM [inaudible]
AND GIVE.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
MY NAME GET NOW I LEAVE
INVESTMENTS FELL ALL AROUND OF
COFFEE.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT LAW
[inaudible]
S. B. [inaudible]
A AT NIGHT FIVE TEN KILL
[inaudible]
LEVINE LADIES OBSERVE THEM ON MY
DAY I'M NOT TRENTON.
I AM LIVE THE DODD NAY AT
CALIFORNIA NOT I COULDN'T HEAR
AND SHE BOUGHT PARA FPE.
EST KNIFE FINE [inaudible]
THINK.
I AM WRONG GRAN ID WE AND NOW
ONLY GOT A FUN YEAH.
HOW SHIP UP AT BE?
I NINE FIVE GOOD MORNING AND
CHEN AMONG MY NAME COUNTRIES
THAT BOY I AM AT LEAVING GOD AND
GROW.
I AM STEP OFF AT ME A LOT FUN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
HIGHER VAN TIGHTLY VIENEN
INVESTMENT DATA AS FAR.
S. B. IT LIFE I THANK YOU.
BUT THEN YOU KNOW.
COLONEL THE HECK NAGANO CITY.
ALREADY GOT THE THE LITTLE HOLE
HERE LOOK.
I HADN'T GOTTEN NAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AMMUNITION
BE BALBOA PARK SAN JOSE I
SUPPORT S. BEING EIGHT NAY PART.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MY NAME
WITH TRYING DOE HAS LEAD TO HELP
CORACIIDAE CALIFORNIA.
I SUPPORT S. B. A KNIFE FIGHT.
WELL IT'S MONDAY LADY AND
GENTLEMAN.
MY NAME IS I TOLD MIKE NINE
PROBLEMS JUNGLE YEAH ISOBAR ES
DE AT NINE FIVE HI WOULD MONNING
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MY NAME
KEVIN HI.
I I SUPPORT TO AT BE A KNIFE I
IF YOU THOUGH IT THEN OF ALL
CONSUMING GOOD YOUNG AND PULL
SAN JOSE ON NIGHT ODIN THEY'D
NAY.
A LOOPHOLE YOU LOOK S. B. FAMKE
NAM SINKING GAP WOULD BE.
GOOD MORNING LADIES GENTLEMAN M.
PHONE NGUYEN FROM SAN JOSE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND GET THE SUPPORT
S. B. EIGHT NIGHT[inaudible]
FIVE YOU.
MY NAME IS A PREDICTOR.
I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO.
I SUB PAR S. B. A KNIFE I THANK
YOU.
THE ONLY ONE HOME.
CAN POSE SACRAMENTO.
SHOULDN'T ALLOW.
YOU WROTE BONTA NUMBER
[inaudible]
COME.
MY NAME'S MELISSA THREE DAHLE I
AM LIVING AT AND GROW.
A CALIFORNIA AYE COMEDIA.
AYE TO SUPPORT SB A KNIFE FRY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAM NO PLAN WHO LEAVE IT
IMPOSE SOME SACRAMENTO COUNTY I
SUPPORT S. B..
A KNIFE FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY LEG QUE TRAN HA I FROM MY
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
SUPPORT SB IT BY FINE THANK YOU.
AND NO GOOD MORNING MY NAME BIG
WIN I AM LIVID OF A MIDWAY CITY
ARE ORANGE COUNTY I SUPPORT S.
B. EIGHT KNIFE I THINK ILL.
BUT THERE LED THE FLOOD CONTROL
SOMETIME BACK --
OR INCULCATE THOUGH PEOPLE YEAR
AT THE TIME TO DO THEM.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SMILING
NGUYEN IF THE US SENATE SAYING
ALSO IN CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT A
S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
AM [inaudible]
DICKMAN.
I AM LIVING IN EL MONTE IT UP AS
HE LET [inaudible]
I SPOKE.
I CAN BE. EIGHT KNIFE FIGHTING
GAME.
SHOULDN'T GALLERY FULL AFFECT
MILLION.
THE YOUNG AYE SHOWS A CERTAIN
WELL.
YOU LOOK THANK THEM WILL COME A
THE ONE IN MY NAY MAYES
BLACKWELL FOOT WITH FROM SAN
JOSE [inaudible]
I SEBAB.
S. BE A BLACK CAR TAKE YOU.
WHEN HONORING?
ARE DONE AYE ENGLAND AYE I WENT
INTO IT YOU KNOW HOW YOU KNOW
HAS TO BE AND YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
THE GUY.
WON'T MONNING LADY AND GENTLEMAN
[inaudible]
I I'M LEAVIN AND THE CPU ON A
HAM.
O. ODIN COLDLY CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE TO TO WALK [inaudible]
THE S. B..
S. NOT FIGHT UNTIL IT A MONTH.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
I WAS THE TEACHER AT THEN.
MACABRE IN JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL IN
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
ON MY NAME IS SCHEME ON DOWN.
AND I CAN CAME HERE FROM.
KERN.
SANTA ANA.
I SUPPORT.
SKINNY EIGHT NINE FINE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS PETER WHERE.
I AM FROM REGARDING GIRL
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
I SUPPORT [inaudible] FORTY S.
B..
EIGHT NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MONEY.
MY NAME THE ISLAM FOUND AYE
LOOKING SALIVATE I SPOKE AT BE A
KNIFE I THINK YOU.
LOOK MONEY IN MY NAME IT LONG
FULL MALL.
ON I LIVE IN PHONE --
SOME JOSE AND I SPOKE S. B.
BASED NIGH HIGH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
MY NAME IS TO HOME WHERE.
OUR EIGHT LA FICKLE ENGINEER.
I LEAVING ON MY ON A RANGE
COUNTY.
I SEE PAUL.
S. ME A KNIFE [inaudible]
FIVE THANK YOU.
NO HAVE MAD THEN HAVE PUT THEY
HAVE NAVY VIETNAM NAVY.
SO I COME HERE I NEED BUT NO AHA
ORANGE COUNTY.
TERRIBLY SPORT THAT AP A
MODIFIED [inaudible]
THANK.
GOOD MORNING I'M HOW YEAH I'M
FROM.
WEST BEAT THE CITY [inaudible]
I SUPPORT.
S. B. A KNIFE I TAKE YOU.
SORRY BAD LEG I HEAR.
ATLANTA IS SHALLOW OUT CAN PULL
THAT ANGLE.
COOL LOOKING ANGLE TO THAT
VIETNAM CAMILLA.
DODIG NOW A DAYS SHIP LAW.
EXCRETE PROMPTED NAM.
PRINT OUT WE I NAMED DE PHAM
SAID THAT I I SUPPORT.
S. B..
A KNIFE I THANK YOU.
HELLO AYE AND HENRY AND I LIVE
IN SACRAMENTO CD AND COUNTY.
I COMMUNITY SUPPORT SP A KNACK
FOR I THINK.
HELLO MY NAME AND MAY WE AND I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO I SUPPLY UP
AT ME PAID MY BY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I AM HAUNTING FROM CHRIS MISSILE
OR A SCOUTING.
I SUPPORT.
IS ME THAT KNIFE I THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MY MY NAME'S LANA WHEN I'M
LIVING IN HUNTINGTON BEACH
ORANGE COUNTY.
I ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT
NINE EIGHT A KNIFE FIGHT.
MY NAME CERTAINLY IN.
I'M.
LIMITED IN GOD ROSY I SAW AND
SUPPORT SB EGGMAN FONG TAKE YOU.
HELLO M. ENEMY HANDING NGUYEN
AND SAID I MENTAL AYE SUPPORTS
AT BE IT KNIFE I FOUGHT RULES
STORY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO THEN BALLOT UP.
GOOD YEAH PLOY SACRAMENTO
[inaudible]
HERE.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS THE THE NOW FOUND.
AND I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO ISA BOX
Y. S. B. AT NINE FIVE GOOD MONEY.
MY NAME MADE IT WHEN I COME FROM
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY HAS A BOOK
TO AT B. NFI.
HE DON'T LEVY THOSE WHO LAW.
A SAN JOSE.
VOTING NAY.
ALONE YOU KNOW.
I'D BE.
FOUND TO NAM THINK AMONG
[inaudible]
HILL.
I NAM MALIAN.
I ATE A BY CPA SALARIES DAY I
SHOULD BALK AT BE A NINETY FIVE
GOOD MORNING.
MYNAME IS THE LOCK MY TEN I
COME FROM [inaudible]
ORANGE COUNTY.
AS A BALK S. B..
A KNIFE I THANK YOU.
MONNING I AM RELYING THEN BAM.
HAVE YOU GO OUT AND COUNTY.
BOB TO SP AT NINETY FIVE GOOD
MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MEN
AND THE TWO BOYS JUNIOR.
AND TAME AND STUFF.
CENTRO CANADIAN REPUBLICS OF
SOUTH VIETNAM SOUTHWESTERN IN
USA.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
S. B. IT NAY FIREFOX TWO STORY
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS FAMILY --
MY RESIDENT IN CALIFORNIA AND MY
OWN TARO IS.
ROSE REAL.
AND I STAND UP HERE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE S. B. EIGHT
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU --
HELLO TORIA AND KNOCKED ON WINE.
I HAD TO DO AND WHO.
JANKLOW IT MEANT THAT BLUE YEAH
I DIDN'T DAY A AYE AND ABOUT HOW
ODD DE L. MALL DO THE CAKE AS
MET DELUDE YOU LOOK --
AT WE PROMPTED NO AND NAM
GOVERNOR.
YEAH THANK YOU.
TIGHT.
GOOD MORNING SO I'D MADAM.
MY NAME IS THE ONE TIME
[inaudible]
LIVING.
AIN'T GOT AND ALL.
AB GAY BEAR DO SO PART.
S. B. IT NOW I FRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
THE FULL.
I AM GENERAL SECRETARY --
HOPE BUFFY DIFFICULT IN ETHIOPIA
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M YET TO
SUPPLY ALL --
S. B.. EIGHTY NINE FIVE THANK
YOU [inaudible] TO MONDAY.
MEN NEVER DO GUY.
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM [inaudible]
VIDEO RENTALS.
LIVING.
A BIG WAY SHE DE.
I SHOULD PARK.
IT BE A LIFE I THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNIN I AM [inaudible]
BY WAY.
I LIVE IN CHERAMAN THOUGH I
THINK BALK [inaudible]
S. B..
A NIGHT BY EDU.
MONNING MY NAME HOW NGUYEN FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HIM ALL DOWN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN.
I SUPPOSE IT'S BE A NINE FIVE
THANK YOU.
DIDN'T OUTDOOR LED TO IT DOWN
JUDGMENT THOUGH KILEY FOR YEAH
DIDN'T AGE IT WON'T YOU LOOK.
AT BE.
A KNIFE I COME ON BUSH MONNING
THURMOND.
AND THE LADY I AM IS A MEANWHILE
I'VE COME FROM THOSE CITIES
SHALL HOLIDAY.
I'M BE HERE.
I'M SPOKE FULL [inaudible]
S. B. [inaudible]
A NINETY FIVE THANK.
LOOK MONNING I AM ONLY YOU.
I COME HERE.
HOW SO QUALIFY AS WE AND MODIFY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO WHAT FELLOW [inaudible]
I SACRAMENTO.
DIDN'T I KNOW HOW YOU KNOW.
AT ME.
DIDN'T TIME THEM.
I'M GONNA KNOW YOU MY NAME
CUTTING WING FROM --
ACCENT WAS A MATTRESS EATEN UP
W. NIMMI AMERICAN CABINET THE
CONDITION NOT ENOUGH COME
CALIFORNIA.
I COMMIT TO SUPPORT SB AT KNIFE
I THINK YOU'LL YOU.
BUT THEN LATE YOUTH HERE.
I THINK IT'S AN FOR SACRAMENTO
SACRAMENTO.
THE OVERHAUL ZERO LOT S. B. DAMN
GENOME.
GOING GALA REBEKAH GROOVY THOUGH
IT ON WINDOWS TANK.
AND IN DATE WITH THE GUY CANYON.
LOS SENIOR INTO --
COULD YOU LOOK AT AND THAT WE MY
THEM MINE LANDFILL DOWN.
LIKE.
SUPPLEMENTAL AYE TO BALK.
AT LIFE BY.
HI MY NAME HI ALL.
I LEVY SORT OF MENTAL.
I COME HERE WITH BOB FD A DYE
PACK.
MORNING MY NAME ANYWHERE FROM
OUR AND OUR COMMERCIAL BULL
[inaudible]
S. B..
I A KNIFE I THINK YOU.
MY NAME HANDY I LEAVE THAT THE
ORANGE COUNTY.
AB FROM CALIFORNIA.
AND I SUPPOSE [inaudible]
ADDED [inaudible] EIGHT WE EIGHT
HUNDRED NOTIFY [inaudible]
THINKING WE I CAN'T EVEN FORM OR
AND CLOUDY.
I SHOULD S. B. AETNA FIRE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME ENVIRONMENT
I I LIVE IN THE ALMOST ON YOUR
LEFT EYE XIN SO BALK.
AT BE.
EARLY LIFE ARE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME ANSWERED JOHN I LEAD
WITHOUT LOUD KNOCK UP WILL YA.
I FOOTBALL.
S. B..
A KNIFE I THOUGHT.
THAT MORNING MY NIGHTMARE HERE
BILL IDEAL WE KNOW SHOVEL YEAH
* DAY HIGH HIGHS ARE TRIPLE.
HADLEY I DO NOT FONG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MORNING.
MY NAME IS A FULLY.
AT LEAL. THREE FIVE SEVEN FIVE
WHAT FOR YOU.
SORRY JAKE CALIFORNIA.
I COSTS ABOUT.
S. P. A NIGHT FLIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
KNOWN.
I AM ONLY.
I AM LONELY I SHOULD FALL
[inaudible]
A THREE I YOU KNOW I DEFY THANK
YOU.
WHAT MONNING YEAH I AM?
MY NAME GO WHEN.
I LEAVE ANYTHING YEAH I COME
HERE.
LOOK WELL FED BE.
LET MY BY THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS ENOUGH THE APPLE.
I AM REPRESENTING THE TO BRING
ALUMNI ASSOCIATION.
I'M LIVING IN WESTMINSTER OFF
ORANGE COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SB EIGHT
NINE FIVE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOSH
LOWENTHAL I'M A RESIDENT OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA.
I AM PROUD TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF S. B. EIGHT NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME JUST
CHAPTER LEAVING SANTANA ALRIGHT
COUNTY ICED UP BALK AT BE AT
NIGHT.
THINK.
MY NAME TO OF ALL.
I NAY LETTER DRAW SHEET THEY
ALRIGHT THEY AYE SIR PAUL
[inaudible]
IT MAY.
A NINE FIVE THANK YOU.
YES MY NAME OF LAND CRAMMED FORM
SIDE IN CALIFORNIA.
I COMEY TO SUPPORT THAT IT BE A
NIGHT BYE THANK YOU.
THINK YOU KNOW.
WHERE THERE ANY --
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES THAT WITHOUT NON STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN ONE TIME COSTS OF ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION.
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
AND ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
CREATES PROP NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES BY
ENCOURAGING LOCAL AGENCIES TO
OFFER THESE COURSES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN NOW QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENT ALSO THE
MEMBERS HERE.
ON I JUST WANT TO FIRST THANK
OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
THEY CAME ALL ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND MOST OF THE
ALLOWED THEM A DRIVEN OVERNIGHT
TO BE HERE ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
SAN DIEGO AND ORANGE COUNTY.
ON AND SABATINO COUNTY AS WELL
UP AS YOU CAN SEE THAT BOTH OF
ENEMIES AND THE COMPUTING
COMMUNITY SHARE VERY SIMILAR
HISTORY OF ESCAPING COMMUNISM TO
SAVE OUR OWN LIVES AND TO BETTER.
AND FIGHTS SPENCER TO FREEDOM
AND DEMOCRACY MY FAMILY IS ONE
OF THOSE AYE --
YOU KNOW CAME HERE WHEN I WAS
FIVE YEARS OLD I NEVER LEARNED
THE ID KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN EXPERIENCE
OF THE REFUGEES --
I HAD TO LEARN WHEN I GOT
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY IT'S
TAKEN ME OVER A DECADE TO LEARN
THE TRUE HISTORY OF THE
STRUGGLES OF MY FAMILY AND THE
PEOPLE OF VIETNAM AS WELL.
AND SO MEMBER I ASK THAT.
CV UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS AND PEOPLE HERE
WHO'VE BEEN HERE.
OF THE LAST SEVERAL HEARINGS
HAVE NEVER TRAVEL TO HE CAPITAL
OR NEVER EVEN KNEW WHAT VOICING
THEIR VOICES MEANT TO THE DOCTOR
TO THE PROCESS OUR DEMOCRACY AND
AND SO I AM SO GRATEFUL THAT
THEY'VE.
HELPED ME IN THIS JOURNEY THIS
IS A BILL THAT HAS BEEN IN
PROCESS SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COMMENTS.
ON BUT I DON'T THINK.
A DOLLAR AMOUNT.
CAN YOU RAISE THE STRUGGLE OF
THE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
THOSE WHO DIED.
AND AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS ALL ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND MILLIONS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES THEIR
HISTORY.
THEIR LIVES.
THEIR VIEWPOINT SHOULD BE HEARD
SHOULD NOT ONLY BE CARRIED ON
INTO THEIR OWN COMMUNITY BUT
SHOULD BE CARRIED ON INTO.
THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WAY WE CAN UNDERSTAND EACH
OTHER WHERE WE COME FROM OUR OWN
PERSONAL STRUGGLE.
AND WE CAN WORK TOGETHER IN
HARMONY AS WELL AND SO AGAIN I
DO APPRECIATE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES.
TAG ON THEM A NUMBER BUT THIS TO
ME IS BEYOND A NUMBER THIS TO ME
IS MILLIONS OF PEOPLES AND THEIR
VOICES NEED TO BE HEARD AND KEPT
IN OUR HISTORY.
BECAUSE HISTORY.
IS NEVER GONNA CHANGE.
WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
I ALSO APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMAN
KARA WHO HAS BEEN A VERY STRONG
VOICE FOR THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY PARTICULARLY
IN SAN JOSE.
AND ALL OF HIS EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF AND
WORKING ALONGSIDE ME WHENEVER IT
COMES DOWN TO FIGHTING AND
SUPPORTING THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND ALL THE MEMBERS THAT --
HAVE ALSO JOIN ME IN THIS OP THE
SHIP AGAIN OF PLEASE ALLOW S. B.
EIGHT NINE FIVE TWO BEFORE TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
AND SO WE CAN CONTINUE ITS
PROCESS.
THEY COMANCHERIA THANK YOU AND I
SPOKE TOO SOON I'M SORRY I THINK
MISS EGGMAN HAD A COMMENT.
I JUST WANTED.
TO VERY BRIEFLY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS UP TODAY I'D LIKE
TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO CAME SO
FAR TO TESTIFY IN TO GIVE YOUR
VOICE.
I'M ASSUMING WHO REPRESENTS A
STOCKTON AREA WHERE I THINK IT'S
SIGNIFICANT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT WE EDUCATE ABOUT IN SCHOOL.
THAT STOCKING WAS THE SITE OF
THE FIRST MASS SCHOOL SHOOTING
AND IT WAS AGAINST SOUTHEAST
ASIANS IN VIETNAMESE AT SOMEBODY
WAS ANGRY --
ABOUT OUTSIDERS COMING INTO OUR
COUNTRY WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
THE LARGER CONTEXT OF AND I WAS
ALSO VERY.
LUCKY AS MANY PROFESSORS AND WE
TEACH WE ALSO LEARN AND I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO THE SACRAMENTO
AREA GET TOGETHER TO HAVE THEIR
OWN GRADUATE PROGRAM OF SOCIAL
WORKERS BECAUSE THEY KNEW THE
ISSUES WERE SO --
IT IS SIGNIFICANT AND DOT I WAS
ABLE LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE --
THEIR PRACTICE INSTRUCTOR AND
REALLY WORKED WITH THE COMMUNITY
TO UNDERSTAND THE LEGACY OF
TRAUMA THAT EXIST IN THE
COMMUNITY AND HOUSING CLINICIANS
AND ORGANIZERS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT.
INTO CONSIDERATION GOING FORWARD
AND SO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE DOING
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I THINK
THE SENATOR --
IN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS AND IF THERE'S
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LIKE TO BE
AS THANK YOU MISCREANT.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS TO OUR ATTENTION AND I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT --
I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WHEN I
WAS FIVE YEARS OLD FROM A SOLID
OR WHICH SUFFERED ITS OWN CIVIL
CIVIL WAR.
AND YOU'VE GIVEN ME ACTUALLY AN
IDEA ON HOW WE CAN POTENTIALLY
TALK ABOUT CENTRAL AMERICAN --
HISTORIES THAT ARE VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT YOU BRING TO THE TABLE
TODAY AND SO I AM SO GLAD THAT
SO MANY MEMBERS OF YOUR
COMMUNITY.
MADE IT TO THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT ALL OF US.
YOU CAN ERASE SOMEONE'S IDENTITY
AND CULTURE OF BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE IN THE HISTORY SO THEY ALSO
SAY THAT THOSE IN POWER ARE THE
ONES THAT WRITE HISTORY.
SOME GLAD THAT WE ARE ALL IN
POSITIONS OF INFLUENCE WHAT WE
CAN TELL THE STORIES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. TWO PEOPLE FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD IN OF CALIFORNIA
IS TO LEAD THEM THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO THANK
YOU ENOUGH.
POSSIBLE IN AND TO ECHO MISS
EGGMAN WHO ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR THINKING.
I'M I BET BRIDGES BABY FOR THE
ALSO A ONE I THINK THE THE CHAIR
FOR HER GENEROSITY IN.
AND AND RECOGNIZING HOW
IMPORTANT WAS FOR S. VOICES TO
BE HEARD SOLO OUTSIDE THE NORM
BUT I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GENEROSITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND OBVIOUSLY AND ANY PLACEMENT
CO AUTHORS IS DEPENDENT UPON ON
THIS MOVIE NOW SUSPENSE TOMORROW.
AND THE FLOOR.
AND I WANNA THANK YOU ALSO FOR
VARIOUS WORD I IN MY CITY
HEIGHTS COMMUNITY AT LIVE AMONG
A NUMBER OF VIETNAMESE AND
CAMBODIAN REFUGEES.
ARE ACTUALLY ON EACH SIDE OF MY
HOUSE -- SO
AND ANYWAYS GREASE YOU.
CAN.
IT MAKES FOR AN INTERNATIONAL
FLAVOR OF SMELLS AT DINNERTIME
COMPARED TO MY NEXT CAN FIT --
BUT IT IT'S IT'S IN MY COMMUNITY
CITY HEIGHTS AND ALSO A VERY
IMPORTANT COMMUNITY THAT WE WE
RECOGNIZE AND I AM I KNOW ALL OF
SYNDICATE AS SO.
THIS WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE --
FILE AND TOMORROW WE WILL SEE
IT'S GREAT BUT THANK YOU FOR
COMING AND THANK YOU ALL FOR AND
EVERYBODY WHO CAME UP HERE I AM.
WILL ALWAYS HAVE A SOFT PLACE IN
MY HEART FOR WELL AND VOICE
THEIR OPINION AND THAT'S WHY WE
ALLOWED SO MUCH LEEWAY --
BUT THAT'S NOT TO GIVE ANYBODY
ANY IDEAS.
THINK.
AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
YOUR GENEROSITY IT REALLY MEANS
A LOT THANK YOU.
WITHOUT MISTER MCGUIRE.
THEY'RE THIS IS THE NAMES OF THE
PETITION WE DID NOT PRINT OUT
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SHEETS AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THIS PROCESS BUT WE
GETS UP TO HAVE THEIR OWN FIRST
NAME LAST NAME CITY AND STATE
FOR YOU HERE AS WELL THANK YOU
CAN GIVE THAT TO THE SERGEANT
THINGS.
ON FOR THEM THANK YOU.
MISTER MCGUIRE.
SP TWELVE FIFTY ONE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I WE HAVE A MISTER BLOW MISTER
BLOOM NOW WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER BLOOM.
AND A SECOND BY MISS CREO THINK
YOU KNOW.
YOU MAY PROCEED WOULD RESPECT WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WE HAVE
A MISS CLARK HERE FROM EDT WHO'S
IN SUPPORT TO BUILD ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I'M SURE THAT THIS
YEAR HAS --
ABOUT TEN OF THEM SO I WILL TURN
BACK TO THE CHAIR.
THINK YEAH.
AND SPEAKERS IN SPORT.
OR AT RISK LIKE WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE WE MANY COMPLIANCE
WITH.
FEDERAL LAWS LEAVING EMPLOYER
TAX CREDITS AND ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING SO HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOUND THAT GETS OUT ON
OF THE ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU.
MISTER HERTZBERG I AM HOPING IS
ON HIS WAY HERE AND I THINK I
MISSPOKE EARLIER IT DOES NOT I
DO NOT HAVE IN MY NOTES MISTER
HERTZBERG IS PRESENTING ON S. B.
TEN THAT WAS AN ASSUMPTION I
MADE.
SO IF I'M THAT HAS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE HOUSE OF YOUR HERE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
ON S. B. TEN YOU MAY LIVE UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND DO THAT AT
THIS TIME JUST YOUR NAME --
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
BEFORE YOU START BUT MISTER
HERTZBERG DOES NEED TO GET HERE
AND PRESENT ON S. B..
TEN OH ONE ON S. B. TIME GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL CANDLE BECAUSE
OUR ON BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION IN SUPPORT THINK YOU.
WHICH IS TAKING SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ON S. B. TENDENCY WAY
PRESENTATION [inaudible]
MARIO.
PLAY DRESS THAT ISSUE MANAGER.
OF COURSE ME.
YEAH I DO UNDERSTAND AND RESPECT
THE THE SENSITIVITY. TO FOLKS
WHO COME TO TESTIFY BUT GIVEN
THE WAVING A PRESENTATION AND
LEAST HISTORICALLY IS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ALWAYS BEEN.
THAT WE DIDN'T PREPARE THE MANY
MANY MANY SUPPORTERS.
OF THIS MEASURE THAT HAVE
APPEARED OVER THE VARIOUS
COMMITTEES IN BOTH HOUSES
THROUGHOUT THE PRESENTATION OF
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
OF THIS LEGISLATION AND I'D LIKE
IF IT'S POSSIBLE --
IT'S IT IF IN THE FUTURE DEEMS
APPROPRIATE TO AT LEAST FRAME
OUT.
A LITTLE BIT OF THE HISTORY
ISSUE JUST BRIEFLY.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARY
JUST IT TO CLARIFY IN THIS IS
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THE FILE QUICKER --
WE ALWAYS OPEN UP AT THE END --
TO PEOPLE TO STATE A POSITION IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO A BILL
THAT'S BEEN WAIVED.
WERE BASICALLY TAKING IT EARLY I
HAD BEEN UNDER THE FALSE
ASSUMPTION I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M
GETTING CONFUSED AT THIS POINT
THEIR HUSKS GOING ON THAT YOU
WERE PRESENTING --
THEIR NUMBER PEOPLE HERE TO READ
JUST.
YOU BASICALLY HAVE A CHOICE YOU
CAN DO A FULL PRESENTATION AND
THEN --
PEOPLE WILL GET TWO MINUTES
OPPOSITION WILL GET TO SPEAKERS
A TWO MINUTES EACH OR THEY CAN
SIMPLY STATE.
THEIR NAMES AND POSITIONS NOW
BUT PER STATE THEIR NAMES AND
POSITIONS BUT I THINK WITH
RESPECT TO THE OTHER MORE
DISTANT YES WE TEN THE OTHER
MATTERS WILL GET AFTER WHICH
WILL LOVE THEM ONTO THE YOU CAN
STAY RIGHT THERE.
LAUNCH YOUR ADDITIONAL DEL AS
SOON AS WE TAKE THIS PUBLIC
COMMENT OUR PUBLIC.
POSITION THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH US HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CHEN MEMBERS ON THE OTHER NUMBER
SAYING NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MY CARE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
IT IT ON THIS PORTION IF YOU
JUST WANT TO SAY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IT IT'S IN NO ORDER
I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU HOLLY HOEKSTRA I
CALIFORNIA BAIL AGENTS
ASSOCIATION BOARD MEMBER ALSO
UPON OWNER OF SMALL BUSINESS
HOLLOW BILL BONDS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO I REDDING
CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION.
HI KELLY WHETHER BE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN SACRAMENTO.
AND NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA BAIL
AGENTS ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB.
TEN THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF LOS
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TWO VERY BRIEF
POINTS.
THE BOARD IS SO NUMBER IF
AMENDED OKAY FOR S. B. TEN TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING AND TO ALLOW THE BOARD
THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT OPERATIONALLY HOW TO PUT
THE PIECES IN PLACE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING AND SO WE WILL
NOT WITH AS THE JUSTICE GROUP OR
AN ORGANIZATION OF WOMEN WITH
INCARCERATED LOVED ONES ORIGINAL
CO SPONSORS OF S. B..
TEN AND IN LIGHT OF RECENT
CHANGES ARE NOW IN OPPOSITION
STANCE THINK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I AM A SHARD TOKI WITH AS HE
JUSTICE GREW.
AND I OPPOSE THIS THANK YOU.
EVAN BUNCH WITH JUSTICE LA
STRONGLY OPPOSE SPT [inaudible]
THANK HIM.
ANDREA RICHARDSON AS HE JUSTICE
GROUP AN OPPOSITION.
HI AT LET ME GARCIA AYE WITH AS
HE JUSTICE GROUP AND ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
SURE YOU KEEP ALSO WHAT THAT'S A
JUSTICE GROSS AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
GOT THAT ENOUGH BY LAST YEAR'S
ALSO WITH AS YOU JUSTICE GROUP
AND ALSO POSE.
IF NOT HERNANDEZ SOME WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA TREES FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND ATTORNEYS IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE.
PORTED THE BUILDING CONCEPT AN
IMPRINT.
POSE AS WE UNDERSTAND IT'S GOING
TO BE AMENDED STRONG OPPOSE.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE AS CURRENTLY IN PRINT.
IF AT ALL A WITH CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR RESPONSIBLE BUDGET A
COALITION OF OVER EIGHTY
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
BAIL REFORM STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. TAN BECAUSE OF THE FISCAL AND
SOCIAL IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL.
JOHN RIFLING HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
SUPPORT BILL REFORM OPPOSE SP.
TEN PETE WHAT LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK SUPPORT
BILL REFORM OPPOSE SB.
TEN DAVID KING TONIC CALIFORNIA
BELL AGENTS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA DEVON TENDS
YA BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IMPRINT
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
AMENDMENTS ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
ON JAY JEROME IN OPPOSITION TO
SB.
TEN MONEY MANAGER MEMBERS RANGE
FROM ROTH OF RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF
OF THE LA COUNTY PROFESSIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
AND THE UC CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN PRINT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PAUL BAUER ON BEHALF OF US ALL
PRO BAIL BONDS IN OPPOSITION.
BROOKS ALISON ON BEHALF OF THE
LATIN IN OPPOSITION.
GREG PADILLA GREG BILLABLE BONDS
NO POSITION.
THANK YOU AND THAT BILL AND IS
MEANT TO THE SUSPENSE FILE IS
THERE ONE MORE.
THAT BILL IS MADE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE --
WILL BE DISPENSED OF TOMORROW
AND THEN HOPEFULLY IT WILL
BECOME MORE CLEAR TO EVERYBODY.
WHAT'S IN PRINT AND WHAT'S NOT.
FOR WHAT WILL BE IN PRINT AND
WHAT'S NOT [inaudible]
WITHOUT THANK.
I THINK I WAS CONFUSED AT THIS
POINT --
WITH PEOPLE'S POSITIONING OF MR
HERTZBERG IN ONE BILL S. B.
[inaudible]
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE WE HAVE.
A MOTION BY --
RIGHT AFTER QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS KOREA WHICH TO AYE
CATHERINE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
BUT SENATORS I'VE PREVIOUSLY
SPOKEN ABOUT THE HUMAN RIGHTS
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL THE
USE OF BOTS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENING IN EVERY HUMAN RIGHTS
TRAGEDY AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
THAT ALSO PREVIOUSLY SPOKEN
ABOUT THE USE OF BOTS
UNDERMINING OUR ELECTORAL
INTEGRITY.
I JUST LIKE TO BRING YOU ONE
ADDITIONAL FACT ABOUT THE USE OF
BUT SOMEHOW INTERFERES WITH OUR
ABILITY TO GOVERN AND TO TALK TO
OUR OWN POPULATION.
FROM MAINE SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS
AND SENATOR ANGUS KING A
REPUBLICAN AN INDEPENDENT.
BOTH REPORTED THIS WEEK THAT
THEY ARE BEING.
THEIR VOICES ARE BEING
OVERWHELMED ON THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA THAT ARE TRACED A BOX
THERE UNABLE TO GET THEIR
MESSAGE OUT TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
SENATOR KAMILLA HARRIS FROM
CALIFORNIA THIS WEEK REPORTED
THAT SHE PULLS DOWN A COUPLE OF
DOZEN FAKE ACCOUNTS MOSTLY ON
FACEBOOK EVERY MONTH HER OFFICE
DOES AS WELL.
WE'VE GOTTEN TO THE POINT WHERE
THIS USE OF BOTS IT'S SO
UNREGULATED AND SO OUT OF
CONTROL AND SO WE RESPONSIBLE
THAT IT'S NOT ONLY DONE WHEN
IT'S DONE TO OUR NATIONAL.
POLITICAL SCENE BUT IT IS
LITERALLY INTERFERING WITH
PUBLIC SERVANTS ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS THE PUBLIC WHICH THEY
SERVE THAT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM
AND I HOPE THAT IT'S ONE THAT
YOU WILL HELP US OVER.
THINK HIM SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCES NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
OUR CONVERSATIONS WHICH WOULD
SUGGEST THE BILL DOES NOT
PREVENT THE CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE
OR ANYBODY FROM USING TEXT
MESSAGING SERVICE SAYS THAT ARE
NOT TIED TO AN INDIVIDUAL PERSON
THAT'S CORRECT TEND. TO ASK FOR
A THAT WAS ACTUALLY DONE WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE BUT TO FEDERAL LAW ON THE
SPECTRES BEING POLITICAL SPEECH
QUIRK.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THE
INTENT IS ON THE RECORD SO THINK
I USE THE INTENT AND IT IS ON
THE RECORD DIRECTLY INCLUDE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND THAT GETS OUT ON
OF THE ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
AND I GUESS THE TWELVE FIFTEEN
AND OF FOURTEEN NINETY THREE
ONCE COMMITTEE BILL THE CONSENT
I UNDERSTAND AND THE SEPTIC
SEWERS MEASURES ON SUSPECTS LIKE
RIGHT YESTERDAY I THINK I AM.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WANNA
REMIND EVERYWHERE IMPACT
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS NOT
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS ARE
SENATORS BUT THAT'S JUST A NOTE.
FOR ALL THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN
CALL TODAY SELL WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN --
NO IT'S USUALLY OUT YEAH.
SORRY I'M SORRY I MISSED IT
EARLIER THAT'S OKAY WE KIND I
ORDERED JUST I TO GET DONE NINE
DON'T LIKE THESE LONG MEETINGS --
YOU WANT TO REGISTER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO A SUSPENSE FILE
TWO DIFFERENT BILLS OKAY GO IT
LOOKS LIKE NOT TAKING TESTIMONY
JUST SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
GO AHEAD LIKE THAT WOULD REALLY
ZZ SORRY A ON HAVE MAYBE A SP --
ONE SIXTY EIGHT OPPOSE A A EN EN
ON GMA.
IT'S WHITE HOUSE BILL.
OUR S. B. --
SEVENTY ONE COALITION OF
INTERPRET WASTE HAULER SUPPOSE
LESS AMENDED.
OF THE COALITION OF FARM BUREAU.
REDWOOD INTERESTS OF ORGANIC
RECYCLERS BIOFUELS INTERESTS --
OPPOSE LESS AMENDED WE HAVE
PROVIDED AMENDMENTS --
THINK IT WOULD GIVE US TO
NEUTRALITY THING TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER
ONE MORE --
SP ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE MISTER
HUESO WAS ON SUSPENSE.
ARM I'M WITH THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING A COALITION OF
CIVIL LIBERTIES IMMIGRANTS
RIGHTS LABOR AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN THE
PREPARATIONS THING